e
since today I do not I haven't heard
from anybody
okay good morning everybody Welcome to
environment agriculture
committee um we are are going to be
having a work session on several bills
uh we're already running a couple of
minutes late so I'm going to open up our
work session um are there any do you
know of there are any members of the
committee out in the
thank
you okay
Freeman and I'd like representative has
Haskins please to lead us in the Pledge
morning Al the of the United States
America and to the rep for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
for thank
you so good morning
everybody welcome
back um we have before us uh several
bills that we want to discuss in work
session and
um I guess representative comto probably
wanted to be included in the uh first
one which is HB I'm going to open up our
our um uh work session this
morning we have uh first HB 153
FN requiring that two or more law
enforcement officers in each County
receive training regarding animal
cruelty and as far as I understand um
representative ktoa has got that in
subcommittee uh working on some changes
to that language uh do you know anything
else about that representative Bixby I
don't no I I don't know anything more
about it okay um and I know um let's see
let's
see okay that subcommittee is animal
protection and Licensing
subcommittee uh with representative kto
chair representative Kenny Freeman H
Haskins and sofikitis um are
all on that and I believe uh
representative kto is going to be
scheduling some sort of meeting fairly
soon okay to discuss
um the bill and potential changes
amendments whatever okay based on
testimony that we heard and some
different ideas about um what would work
and what wouldn't
work any other questions or comments
regarding HB
153 representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair in the absence of the chair
of the subcommittee I would say that we
don't have any new information
okay I I do understand that um based on
testimony representative ktoa had some
ideas about yes how she wanted to make
some changes to it representative P
perhaps I I I assume we're expecting her
in a little while yeah she's in the
chair's Vice chairs meeting okay so
maybe we can just return to this when
she gets back sure we'll do that and I
just not I just realize that um my
Amendment for the second bill from now
is sitting upstairs so I'm gonna just
so
okay um now our next bill that we wanted
to discuss was
hp215 FN requiring a landfill permit
applicant to submit a report listing
potential harms and benefits of the
project and I believe that was also
um sent to a subcommittee if you'd like
to give us a a report of that
representative King yeah so that was
sent to solid way subcommittee and um
representative ger is uh Leading The Way
with uh amendments and working with the
um with the department and maybe he can
speak more on that but what I plan on
doing is just once I find out next week
when we're going to meet for our regular
committee I'll just schedule um schedule
our subcommittee to meet 1 hour before
then and I'll send an email out to
everybody and that'll be for both 2:15
and 240 okay I can give you that now
because I was working on the committee
Tuesday
um I am planning a
caucus uh for for us between n any could
be 915 to 9:30 but um we're going to
start our our work here here at 9:30 so
if you want to schedule something before
then yeah we'll probably meet around uh
8:15 then I'm assuming that would give
us a full hour probably won't need that
I'm I'm imagining but gives us a full
hour and then we'd still have time for
caucuses
so okay so that would be Tuesday
February 11 and that's when your
subcommittee would work and to do that
and I'm I'm imagining
that we would be able to EXA that bill
Tuesday February 18 so that gives you
about a week um to work on amendments or
whatever representative gerana U thank
you madam chair yeah just so a quick
update on this bill I did meet with uh
director whims on Friday and um I'm uh
we've got some really cool ideas I think
about how to amend the bill along the
lines that the committee had discussed
one of things that we're looking at is a
having a preliminary screening phase
which is where the the the net public
benefit would be determined and we
talked about how that could be written
in such a way as to allow Dees to
collaborate with some other agencies uh
and and also to flesh out the benefits
side of of things uh in that bill right
now we've got a list of potential harms
but the only benefit currently in
statute as we've talked about is
capacity need so we're also looking at
introducing some langu
that would uh include some other
possible benefits economic benefits
infrastructure benefits so to create a
balanced list of both potential harms
and potential benefits oh that sounds
good so um I have a draft of that
language I have sent to the director to
ask for his feedback on uh and so an
amendment is in the works along those
lines okay sounds
good any other comments questions about
HB 215
seeing
none um moving on to HB 240 removing the
penalty of forfeiture for non-payment of
dog
licenses and I understand representative
Bixby that you have an amendment for
that
bill and seeing as that we're planning
on executing that this morning
um I think that
uh going over this would be a good a
good thing okay so um so just uh just a
review to uh turn the the list of um
many many numbers into actual uh words
um this bill is about um the this bill
was brought forward because of a concern
about the uh way that um for fure of uh
pet
dogs uh comes up in the statutes and uh
as a potential penalty for failing to
pay uh your dog license or or failure to
license your dog and uh the way that it
is currently written in statute uh it
says that uh the city city government
shall send a uh warrant to the person
who is not cooperating uh which would
threaten to confiscate the dog uh the
way that there are no so far we had no
evidence of any confiscations happening
uh for this purpose in the state we just
uh but it does and uh we have evidence
that uh government officials seem to try
to find a way to work around this uh but
in fact it does say in statute that they
that that warrant shall be issued uh the
there is a May in terms of the
confiscation but in terms of the issuing
the warrant is a shall um and uh this
was an issue for concern uh for the
constituent one of the constituents of
the Prime sponsor uh and this so
um the committee last week uh pretty
much said that uh they felt that um
figuring out some way to establish
leeway on the part of government uh
municipal government officials in terms
of the issuing of the warrant would be a
good way to go and uh so I was thinking
about how to do that and I thought you
know maybe it requires a full a full
sentence of explanation or maybe it just
requires a a one-word change so and I
wasn't sure so I just went to OS because
they have really good people there who
can uh help you figure out uh what needs
to happen so I brought it to OS and they
and um the person I was working with
said basically the simplest and more
straightforward way to do this is just
to change the Sha to a May that provides
the leeway for the government officials
it doesn't create a list of exceptions
BEC and which is a good thing because
whenever you start a list of exceptions
it gets longer and longer and longer and
less and less wieldy so uh this is the
most efficient way to do it I think um
and it just in line 11 changes the word
shall to the word May and that gives
enough leeway for the
um uh for the municipal
officials okay um representative k
please take your seat representative
King thank you madam chair uh
representative Bixby did you um converse
with um the sponsor of the bill at all
and see if he was u a a to this change
yes I had an email exchange with him and
he said oh that's much simpler than what
I was thinking and much better thank you
very
much
okay okay sounds good uh anybody have
any questions or comments or concerns
about
hb24 okay seeing none thank you
um since representative ktoa is here um
I want to just circle back to the HB 153
bill as we're talking about in for the
work session um requiring that two or
more law enforcement officers in each
County receive training regarding animal
cruelty do you have any update for us on
uh thank you madam chair um the
committee I believe will be work U
meeting on February 14th um I believe
that I just have to double check with
members but I think most are available
at that time um I'd also like to know if
they're available at 9:00 a.m. as
opposed to a 10:00 a.m. start but we can
talk about that after so that is the
plan is to have a work session on that
right representative Bixby so uh are you
uh going to be looking into the notion
of the task force that the uh person
from uh police training mentioned uh I I
think we're going to explore all avenues
I think that's the way to go um and uh I
wasn't here for his particular testimony
but I uh was trying to look for the
video last night um to go over that but
if you have his name uh that'd be great
okay
thanks
okay okay so then uh we can move on to
HB
566 requiring permit applications for
new landfills to contain a detailed plan
for lee8
management uh representative king would
you give us an update on that so the
information in regards to 566 is the
exact same as 2115 I misspoke earlier I
think I said uh 240 was the other bill
yeah so HB 566 will be discussed in your
subcommittee as well yeah
um and that's also going to happen on
next next Tuesday morning okay super any
other questions or comments or com
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I just want to say for the record
that I heard some of the most compelling
testimony on that bill that I've heard
in this committee though
far okay thank you representative ger
thank you madam chair just very quickly
I just that again I've spoken with
director whimet we're working on
language my intent is to have amendments
prepared for our subcommittee meeting uh
on 5 566 and 171 okay thank you
um is
what what's the thrust of uh changes
that would occur for that
bill so with uh
566 the lee8 management uh there was a
kind of draft of language I shared with
the committee uh last time last week and
that has been submitted uh as an
amendment so the amendment to that bill
is uh already in the works and the
committee has seen the language that we
that we're putting into an amendment and
I can recirculate it if folks would like
and with 171 last week director whim sat
uh had some advice for some technical
changes to language and uh he is going
to get that to me this week and so there
some small changes but uh in the wording
to make it more technically correct for
for HB 171 yes for 171 okay thank
you um all right
so is is HB 171 also going to be
discussed in your
subcommittee we hadn't uh we hadn't sent
it there yet but we can if if we if
everybody's amenable to that I have no
problem all right
um okay so yeah that would work great
because my again my plan is to have an
amendment to share uh by next week so it
would be easy enough to bring that
Amendment to the solid waste
subcommittee so we can discuss it
uh okay and what's the nature of the
change
I haven't seen the specific uh language
that the director recommended yet so I'm
waiting to hear from the director as he
said it's a change not to the content
but some of the technical language of
that bill okay thank you represent Bixby
yes one of the issues uh that D director
whtat brought up is that there is
currently in statute a um a provision
that says that if a department hasn't
acted on a bill within a certain time
window and I think it's like three
months then the then it automatic then
the rules go into effect automatically
without uh without any changes so um so
in or no not not not a rule not a rule a
permit so if if the depart if a
department receives a permit and uh they
don't uh they they don't act on it in
any way to either approve it or deny it
then it automat automatically gets
approved within three months oh that's
not good uh that was uh well I that's
the way it is and I I didn't vote for
that one myself but that's that's been
in law for about uh four four or five
terms now um so
um uh but in any case he pointed out
that that law would come into effect and
there is a way there's a relative he
also pointed out there's a there are a
couple of Rel atively straightforward
ways of dealing with it so that it won't
come into effect but uh but that it
needs to be dealt with or else
um permits would just get automatically
approved okay yeah so what represent I'm
sorry thank you m sure uh yeah and thank
you representative Bixby uh for
reminding us because I'd forgotten about
that part yes so I think that in the end
We'll add a notwithstanding Clause uh in
order to deal with that but thank you I
do remember that was one of the the
technical language issues that is being
addressed in an amendment okay thank you
represent Penza oh she had her hand up
no she's
not never
mind okay uh any other questions or
comments regarding HB
566 and uh also HB
171 any other no okay I guess when
representative Penza returns we can ask
her okay
um HB
179 relative to hazardous waste accident
fees
um does anybody have any questions or
Bill okay um this is a work session for
committee members but um if if everybody
is fine with that we can uh speak with
representative P representative Bixby
yeah I'd just like to make a note
initially that uh I think that the idea
behind this bill is very important we
need to make sure that our uh
firefighter fighting uh operations get
reimbursed for equipment that's damaged
due to uh reasons beyond their control
but I think that the mechanism that was
proposed in the bill initially doesn't
work so I'm I'm eager to hear what the
amendment looks like and uh and then we
can work work from there to see if uh
that will get the results that we want
okay any other questions or comments
before represent P I invite you to come
to the table there you can pass out your
copy of your Amendment and we can
discuss uh how these changes might
morning Madam chair and the rest of the
committee uh the last time we spoke I
was suggested that I clean this up it
did okay how does so no payment plan as
it was described it's just a straight
penalty $1,000 a day after the 90 days
of
non-payment until they pay the bill
Yeah question representative uh comto
thank you madam chair so the only change
here that I see is that you took out
interest assessed at the rate of a right
and no was like a
20% not in this section it was plus
interest we talked about it but we took
out the interest just a straight
penalty uh nothing else okay thank you
thank you chair uh thank you for your
proposed amendment um I was reading this
and the question I have for you is um
are there similar rsas where fines and
colle fines that are charged against
someone for violation rues so forth are
have been collected in that procedure
that's working now that we could adopt
an existing Fine Collection system or
fee collection system that's in another
RSA I'm not sure okay okay represent
Bixby okay so um you had mentioned when
you were uh speaking last week that uh
the the it sounded kind of like the
fines would go towards paying the
balance of the charge and I just want to
make sure that in this case the the the
uh the charge to the um per to the um
person who's against whom the claim is
being made is is still is separate from
the from the penalties that any penalty
is on top of that correct they have a
Bill of X and then after n 90 days
$1,000 penalty per day will be
charged with that with that initial on
top of that initial bill okay I think
this provides a a sufficient
stick representative coma thank you
madam chair um in listening to your
testimony it seemed like a lot of the
um this comes from insurance companies
correct um however the claimant would be
whoever holds the policy if the
insurance company doesn't pay the
claimant uh for 180 days then they're
still have to pay the fine of the $1,000
per day for an additional 90 days
correct I would say so but anybody that
deals with hazardous
materials has to have a million at least
a million dollars of insurance for a
spill as I understand it okay you
followup so what I'm saying is is for 90
days if the insurance company doesn't
get that claim paid within the initial
90 days the claimant is then on the hook
for an additional thousand for the next
90 days is that correct so I would
assume it would be the insurance company
because they are the party that is
responsible to pay the
bill right because the the operator of s
facility has insurance to cover that to
take the responsibility for
that I I understand what you're saying
I'm just reading the Bill thank you okay
so I have a concern about this as it
might relate to
homeowners homeowners that may not know
that they have a hazardous you know
hazardous material um you know an
underground oil tank or some other kind
of
um so as containers as I understand it
oil uh tanks are covered by homeowners
insurance so when they let go the
insurance kicks
in and and and if not I believe a lot of
the oil companies have spill mitigation
uh that will come in and clean up the
oil okay but I'm still concerned that um
homeowners could be stuck with this if
the insurance company's not paying the
bill or for for whatever reason that a
homeowner may be the one subjected to um
this kind of fine which is a you know a
hefty exorbitant fine correct and and I
see that you know you're you're you're
in your thought you're directing this to
collecting funds from uh insurance
companies but what
happens in the case that you know there
is no maybe the homeowner doesn't have
ins homeowners insurance so as you heard
in in testimony before we've had very
few
home in
home hasmat incidents that the team has
been called out
to and and you also heard that a couple
of them have never paid and we've never
pursued it because we understand you
cannot get blood from a stone right so
it
doesn't help us or to say we're going to
find you when we know there's no money
there right and move on and most of
those small spills are very small in a
home and can be handled quite easily at
very little expense okay but would we
should we do you believe should we put
some sort of exemption on
homeowners uh who you know maybe cannot
pay that or
whatever if if we could develop some
sort of language that would um make sure
that the homeowner is protected uh from
EX AB Orbin at
fees are they going to be responsible to
pay the
fee um well you you're you're going
You're primarily looking for payment
from insurance companies correct okay
there's a way so if there's no insurance
company then probably not going to go
after it yeah but all right um
representative Freeman you had your hand
up and then representative minor I did
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming in front of US Representative so
I I want I kind of wanted to pull back
to the original attent of the bill which
was the fact that small fire departments
who had been engaged in um in mitigating
hazardous materials could no longer use
their Hazmat gear because it was
contaminated and subsequently the money
was falling on the local taxpayers to
replace that gear is that not correct
that is correct so may I have a follow
thank you very much so basically what
this and and through your testimony you
had stated that 99% of those
instances are corporations businesses
people who deal with hazardous materials
all the time and only maybe 1% were
private residences is that correct that
is
correct follow up thank you very much so
in order to mitigate the damages to
these small fire departments and not
pass the burden on to the local
taxpayers your bill wants to be able to
go after those companies directly in
order to collect the money in order to
replace your hasm suits is that correct
correct thank you okay representative
Miner thank you madam chairman thank you
representative Pro for um testifying
again before us today uh a question on
what constitutes a spill how many
gallons constitutes a spill when does
Hazmat have to get
involved they just changed it what is it
now
15 Gallons
petroleum gas oil or such so after that
it kicks it up um but other houses um
materials that may be poisonous or um
acidic or alkaline sure uh maybe a
smaller amount okay thank you
okay okay representative Howard thank
you madam chair and hello representative
um would would there be a a lower risk
to um the materials and the and the gear
that you use when you have when you deal
with an
underground tank like you would with a a
domestic situation correct so
underground tank that leaks we may never
be even called except to maybe uh assess
the the situation because there's no
active um hazard to the house next door
or anything like that because know the
fumes are out in the air so they whoever
owns that tank is now going to be
responsible to get a cleanup company to
come in and mitigate that yeah sure
followup so so would that just indicate
a lesser risk or um to the department in
a in a domestic situation and therefore
sort of an implied um um
exemption
yeah okay representative Bixby so
um there is a uh oil spill mitigation
fund uh which is used in part to do
ProActive Management by replacing tanks
that are getting more helping people
replace tanks that are going getting
worn out and I believe that fund can
also be used to help clean up with
spills does uh do fire departments ever
are are they able to access access any
of those funds to replace equipment or
is that totally separate I believe it's
totally separate but I'm not 100% sure
on that thank you I think we would need
to do some investigating on that on that
point I think I I think that for the
purposes of this bill I think I my guess
is that it it's it doesn't it's not
going to play a whole lot of role in
this bill and the only question is do we
want to include some sort of language
that provides leeway on the part of the
um the uh Department that's enforcing
the uh this charge to the responsible
party right uh so
uh I'm okay with putting something in
for uh if the homeowner's insurance
doesn't pay then we will not go after
the
homeowner representative Kwa thank you
madam chair um
a concern I have here and is with the
agriculture uh and the hobby farmer um
who has uh pesticides and as we just
heard 15 gallons of petroleum is not a
lot of petroleum if you have
tractors and even though you might be
doing everything properly um on your
farm and having a diesel tank outside
and having it on that cement slab and
making sure all the proper guidelines
but if something happens or something
catches on fire
um based on the criteria 15 Gallons some
that's going to require Hazmat based on
um for that to kick in based on what you
what we were just told 15 gallons of
petroleum is that correct that is
correct so um so for the committee I I
just want us to really consider um the
consequences that it could have have on
our hobby farmers in our agriculture in
the state um we are all anyone that has
pesticides on their property is required
by law that sprays uh is required by law
to have a um pesticide license uh if
they're selling their product and um one
of the things that we go over and in the
classes and everything and is how to
mitigate possible spills or leakage or
any of that stuff and I would hope that
most of them have insurance um and that
the insurance company would pay in a
timely manner however if they
don't and we say that they'll be
responsible for the additional fees but
the insurance company actually decides
what they're going to pay it's not up to
the homeowner and that really concerns
me so that's just my thoughts and I know
representative Bixby
I I think we also have to be um
cognizant of of a sense of scale here
and what we're what we're talking about
is uh a hazardous waste release that is
of sufficient size to damage the fire
firefighters uh equipment and if we're
talking about a gallon or two of uh
Roundup that's probably not of the scale
that's going to cause a huge problem um
or or you know
whatever um pyin
or uh the the scale that uh that a hobby
Farm is going to have pesticides at that
is unlikely to cause a whole lot of
damage to firefighting
equipment um no it would be correct but
I'm so I'm wondering if it would be more
acceptable I'm sorry yeah I will get to
represent wheeler uh I I'm wondering if
it would be more acceptable to say in
addition to this amendment a penalty of
$1,000 per day will be paid to the
claimant for each day of non-payment
Beyond 90 days unless
other uh Arrangements have been made or
are made is that something no I don't
know okay all right representative
wheeler thank you madam chair I was
going to say much of what representative
Bixby said about the amount of spill
causing damage on the firefighter's
equipment it would take a pretty
significant spill in a hobby Farm to
cause the damage that we're talking
about here to the firefighters gear and
in my opinion if that did happen on a
hobby farm that goes onto the taxpayer's
dollar if we don't have someone who's
paying it and and and that farm is
responsible if if they damage the
firefighters gear to the point where the
they need to seek uh some kind of uh
fixing that gear then the taxpayer
should not be burdened with that
person's
transgression on on the town uh so I I
would hope that to me this legislation
is properly written as it as it stands
you would get an initial bill for
whatever damage you you incurred and
then after that if you don't pay after
90 days there'd be a $1,000 a day you
know who knows what that bill might be
maybe it's $25 in damage you know if
it's a hobby Farm I would assume it
would be not the $50,000 in damage that
representative PR brought for it as an
example example when he brought this
bill for it I think it would be
significantly less and then for some
reason if you don't pay after 90 days
that significantly less bill I don't see
a problem with incurring a fine of
$1,000 a day even if you're a
homeowner representative
ger thank you madam chair and and I
share the concern about the individual
homeowner and if if there's some way we
can kind of provide safeguards for that
uh and and also for representative
comtois points about Hobby Farmers uh
the one thing that does concern me
though is that if people are genuinely
negligent with the storage of things so
I don't know if it's possible you know
if there's a determination when you look
at the the cause of the fire if there's
a determination that it was caused by
negligence right if if there can be a
distinction there right because to me if
if if you are negligent in the storage
of these chemicals and it results in a
fire and it damages equipment then you
should be on the hook for it however if
you have been doing everything right and
it was not your fault that this happened
that to me is is someone who shouldn't
be hit with such a heavy F so I don't
know if there's a way to make a
distinction based upon the determination
of the cause of the fire and whether or
not negligence was a contributing factor
okay representative Freeman and saitis
thank you madam chair um representative
would you would you be I can't see now I
took my glasses off that was silly um
would would you be agreeable excuse me
to amending the amendment to include the
language um something like unless other
arrangements for payment have been made
and that would cover everybody's
concerns about Hobby Farmers
homeowners if there's some latitude to
allow those fire departments to make
payment arrangements and take it by a
case take it on a Case by case situation
instead of just an overall
generalization I think that might
address the issues that are coming up
which are all very valid but this bill
would be 17 pages long if we did that so
that that might help to just allow them
the latitude to get what they need to
get but know that whoever they're
dealing with will be handled on a
case-by casee basis representative
sofikitis
good morning good morning do you know
what's the practice in other
states for this sort of
thing usually in other states their
Hazmat teams are funded by the
state okay and this problem does not
exist thank
you representative Bixby thank you for
asking so um I'm I've been thinking a
little bit about the phrasing of this
and um and how this and and I'm
beginning to remember how this is on uh
phrased in in other statutes having to
do with particularly with
departmental uh penalties for violation
and usually the phrasing is a penalty of
no greater than x per day so if we
change this to a penalty of no greater
than $1,000 per day that would allow the
municipality uh to say uh if if it's a
case of a homeowner whose insurance
claim has being delayed they could
say uh we see you're working on it your
penalty is going to be you know for the
you know as long as you are continuing
to pursue this appropriately your pen
penalty is zero uh and if uh so so and
and it could be scale anywhere in there
depending on how big a stick is needed
to uh get compliance but I think that
the goal of getting compliance is really
the key to this and uh if you have
someone who is uh really being
belligerent then you need a big stick
but if you if you have someone who's
cooperating then you can uh you don't
need the
stick representative wheeler and then
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair if someone is not paying for 90
days they're not cooperating and I think
that they should incur a fine for
damaging the gear of the firefighters
out but what we're talking about here is
$1,000 per day after 90 days of
non-payment so you get a bill and you
don't pay it for almost two months and
and three months thank you can't count
obviously the for almost three months
and then we're worried about the $1,000
a day fine that to me is silly if you
damage the firefighters Hazmat gear in a
situation where there is necessary to
have Hazmat gear which would be a pretty
intense situation especially if if it
was damaged and you don't pay for 90
days after that situation or you get the
bill I I think that you should incur
$1,000 fine okay representative ktoa and
then Scully and then Bixby thank you
madam chair and and thank you can you
tell me how your gear gets
ruined in a hazardous with hazardous
materials say whether it's petroleum
or so a lot of times that cannot be
removed it it'll eventually start
degrading the material of the Hazmat
suit depending on the
chemical again I have uh uh the chief
back there who has better knowledge of
that may Madam chair sure so what you're
saying is if petroleum gets on the suit
it's basically ruined correct because I
really don't like going into a fire with
oil all over my gear that that that
would um make perfect sense so it could
be any amount of
petroleum one little dot no my whole arm
is covered yep and what would cause your
whole arm to be covered well when I'm
walking in a pool of oil and my feet
come out from underneath me because it's
that
slippery I was covered from head to toe
okay thank you represent Skully thank
you madam chair and thank you again for
coming before us um again I
as it's currently worded I am troubled
because of the lack of protections for
homeowners and small farmers um I'm
troubled that there's no proportionality
uh regarding how much you want to charge
people in relation to what the actual
bill is and I'm troubled that there's no
cap so that if you had a $5,000 bill
theoretically you could end up charging
for somebody a hundred times that
because of of the delay in getting
payments so I'm just letting you know
that as it's written now I I I'm
troubled with it I represent and if I
can answer that okay I'm sorry we're not
going to go after the 5,000 it's
$178,000 for gear
equipment and materials used right the
small house and the the the farmer AR
aren't the problem because in 15 gallons
of oil I don't fall down in and and we
can mitigate that quite easily right 20
gallons maybe even 100 gallons but when
you get up to 1,000 gallons 3,000
gallons of oil on fire at you that's
that's a whole different situation
somebody spills a little extra
pesticides not a big deal that can be
handled quite
easily represent big spe but I'm I'm
willing to to put something
in yeah I I think that um
the the issue of the 90 days I I think
that we do need to provide some
flexibility there because um I don't
know how many of us have had to deal
with an insurance company getting to and
getting them to pay a bill but it is not
always an easy process and it doesn't
always happy happen within 90 days and
we don't want to create a penalty where
there is no leeway for someone who is
trying earnestly to get their insurance
company to pay up and and uh and the
insurance company is being slow on the
other hand we do need to have some sort
of Stickin law so I think that the idea
of having it up to then gives the
municipality clear legal leeway to say
okay we're not going to charge the
penalty we know you're working on
it okay uh representative saitis here
previously no worries um perhaps you or
the chief could give us a
ballpark of how much this hazardous
suits
up
R 50,000 the last incident we've had
50,000 for
eeping uh so how much each suit so all
the suits we spend 5,000 for each
suit they're
expensive does that include the house
sorry doesn't include the helmet go
ahead okay thank follow up yeah you're
you're okay okay representa Howard thank
you madam chair so um I just want to
reiterate that uh what um representative
Bixby has been saying that um having a
little bit of leeway about how much you
penalize people gives you room
at the municipality at um level to to
understand people's circumstances in
their ability to pay and um and I think
that
uh I another Point sorry I think I might
have forgotten it but um but I I do
think that that's that that oh I know
what it was if we take if we put too
many conditions in here we're going to
take the teeth out of it so I think that
that simple phrase from from
representative Bixby or something like
any other questions
comments anybody have any other
questions for represent
P okay so um clearly we'll um have to
work on an amendment for this and uh
would you like me to get
it um perhaps somebody would work with
I I think the only the only point I'd
like to make is that the bill is now the
Committees so it should be a Committee
Member who is the lead sponsor on the
amendment right so which and that so if
you want to work with representative PR
on it that would be great but I would
appreciate I would appreciate it
representative Bixby if you would
consult with us as well absolutely
because I think we're saying the same
thing but in a different manner so I I
think it would be important to drill
down on that I think I have I think I
can cover in about three minutes the
wording that we need to change it to
perfect thank you so much but I really
want to stress the concerns that
representative coma has um be recognized
for whatever in whatever amending
language you figure out so in terms of
the in terms of the penalty having it
possible for the municipality to say the
penalty is zero going forward solves
that entirely if you want but if you're
getting into how much is the how much is
the charge for the damaged equipment
that is um that's a calculation that
happens in a different paragraph of the
law than this bill is dealing with and
uh would probably require a much more
extent I I suspect that would May well
be a non- gerine Amendment and would
require new um uh a new hearing so or or
it might be another bill but it so so I
think that for the purposes of this bill
uh and and I I guess the other thing is
that problems have not cropped up with
the other parts of the statute it's just
the getting people to uh getting large
offenders to pay up is is the problem so
I think that we we don't need to drill
into the rest of the statute I think
that if we just um make the amendment to
the bill that will give the leeway that
uh to have the penalty range from zero
to a thousand um that will solve the
issue Representatives uh grber and then
ktoa um representative scully's uh uh
concerns I I think are very important to
take under consideration too I support
many of the things most the things you
said in your Amendment representative K
thank you madam chair and
um I appreciate um the wording no
greater than um that representative
Bixby has
suggested um what if and I'll just I
mean I always do the wh ifs um someone's
homeowner's insurance or insurance
doesn't
cover um do you and the other thing was
is it seems like this bill has been
being brought forward for a very
specific accident that has happened I
don't believe this can be done this will
go retroactive and will affect that will
it represent Bixby legislation is never
retroactive thank you no and it's not
just the one the one was the straw that
broke the camel's
back
okay okay um any other questions or
comments okay so um representative
Freeman representative Bixby and also
representative ktoa if you can kind of
get together and figure out
agree on language that would that would
be helpful represent representative
Scully as well um and then I guess we
can uh we'll figure on on on an
amendment being brought for that and uh
we can uh talk about that probably next
week before I'm I'm planning
on next
week um planning on executing that bill
next week so
uh we can have that Amendment ready and
we can discuss it prior to uh executing
that Bill yes okay
super that's the
hr10 oh oh that's right I'm looking at
the public hearing hello yeah okay I'm
looking at the wrong paper I'm sorry my
apologies um so yeah we are supposed to
be looking at
hr13
Y and
hr13 thank you gentlemen for joining us
this morning and lending your uh your
input appreciate it
hr13 um which is a house resolution
opposing the permitting of a landfill
next to Forest Lake State Park in Dalton
New
Hampshire and um so we heard that bill
house resolutions um questions comments
about
that representative Bixby yeah so
um I think that uh the idea of um making
a statement opposing permitting landfill
next to uh Forest Lake State Park in
Dalton is entirely consistent with uh
the legislative track record of this
committee for the last several terms uh
and uh it is also consistent with uh the
corner office position on this uh so far
as has been publicly stated uh I think
that in that I don't see a whole lot of
controversy on this uh we also need to
keep in mind that uh house resolutions
are really a statement of collective
opinion as opposed to any having any
sort of legal weight so um I think that
uh it is a I think it's a good gesture I
don't think that uh and I'm I'm hoping
that we can get it to pass with a with a
fair number of votes in the house um and
I think that typically when we assuming
that that we can pass this out of
committee unanimously which I would like
to see um we typically put that sort of
thing on the consent calendar in this
case I think it would make sense to
actually have a
brief
um a brief uh Speech from the well about
it uh just to um sort of let people know
what it is that the H let everyone in
the house know what position what uh
statement is being
made representative
wheeler thank you madam chair uh I'm
generally against resolutions just
because they don't have teeth it's a
waste of paper yada y y but the Dalton
landfill is one I think worth moving
forward on and I'll be voting for The
Resolution you know got John Swan right
here he's worked very hard on the Dalton
landfill water Warriors that are up
there that are urging the legislature to
do something about this and I think
making a short statement and I wouldn't
support this if it was just a statement
but because we have so many pieces of
legislation about landfills I think that
it's important to make the statement and
then also pass the legislation with
teeth to make sure that that we have
clean safe environment in the state of
New Hampshire representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair I just want to go
on record uh echoing my two previous
colleagues sentiments we've come a long
way on this issue and I think it's now
time for the legislature to say this is
our position we've done the work now we
need to get it across the Finish Line in
every way that we can thank you okay
representative Miner
thank you madam chair although the house
resolution really does have no teeth I
think it's an important statement that
we all uh agree on that uh uh this um
house resolution should go through thank
you represent
STIs thank you madam chair um I just
would like to make a public statement
about um my appreciation for um Mr Swan
for the work that he's done um
because when we first started having the
talk about Forest Lake many years ago it
was just a small group of people but now
we have come to the point where
um there are constituents up there and
they're asking us to act and by putting
out something like this that we can pass
hopefully on the other side side of the
wall we can get it through and um with
the governor having um made a public
statement about it I'm hopeful that this
is the year thank you representative
Freeman and then representative Scully
um thank you Madame chair um I'm I'm not
going to make a statement because th
this is really a no-brainer to vote for
this resolution but I'm just curious on
when we as a committee and and and a
body feel that we should get a bill to
make this really solidify this and
codify this into law and I think that's
what we should be working on after we
passed this house
resolution representative Scully and
then
Penza thank you
um I'm in support of the spirit of this
um I think that from my perspective when
I you create a house resolution it
should be something that is short and
piy and can be read from the well and I
think this is so long and unwieldly that
you really can't do it so if the
intention was to actually speak to the
body and have them uh agree with the
sentiment I I would just suggest that
this be drastically shortened U to get
to the point so that we could read it
from the floor and then people could um
agree with it representative
Penza good morning morning I'd like to
um just respond to representative
Freeman's statement we have lots of
bills in right now and we are going to
hear one this afternoon that will
um that would stop uh a landfill in its
tracks um being built in poor soil so
but the other piece that is huge for
This Is Us passing a
moratorium um a pause I hate the word
moratorium um but a pause basically so
then we can work with the agency um get
good legisl on the um legislative pieces
on the books and move forward from that
so I support this resolution um I
understand where you're coming from I
kind of heard that um at the end of the
last hearing from representative Scully
I don't believe that we're going to read
the whole resolution on the house floor
um there's so much backstory people have
been fighting on this for um I think
we're going into our sixth year um we
need to do this for the people
representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and I'd like
to just Echo what um representative
Skully also stated but this doesn't just
there's more wording in this resolution
than just the Dalton landfill um so if
the idea was
to you know prevent the Dalton landfill
next to Forest Lake State Park that's
one thing but there is a lot of wording
in this resolution that is outside of
that scope and I don't think
um with that and good conscious I could
vote for the resolution as it
stands representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I wanted
to reiterate what uh representative
Scully said I wonder if instead of
reading the whole resolution if there
isn't a a Artful way to summarize it
without having to rewrite the whole
thing because it is very long and I and
I think we would lose people if if we
were to stand up there and read directly
by wrote from the from the page
representative
guber um thank you chair uh I fully
support this uh resolution um I think
the legislature needs to take a strong
stand with over the years of people
looking at what's happening and and the
and the mission of this uh committee
itself U yes I believe it is too long to
read um but and maybe that could be
modified but I I strongly support it
representative Bixby yeah so um
uh the
first uh three pages of the resolution
are essentially citing all of the
existing or or many of the existing uh
positions that the state of New
Hampshire has about a number of things
having to do with Environmental
Protection and safeguards for our
natural environment uh the Crux of the
resolution is basically just what is on
page four which is one sentence uh that
the general court resolves to protect
the interest of the state and the
citizens by asking the New Hampshire
Department of environment and services
the governor the Attorney General to
take all appropriate legal actions
against permitting a Le landfill next to
Forest Lake State Park in Dalton that is
all we need to read from the so if we
read that from the well and we preface
that by saying that the bulk of the
resolution is just providing all of the
background in state policy that supports
it uh I think that's a less than one
minute well speech at the
well representative
ger thank you madam chair so I'm glad to
hear it seems that we've got consensus
behind the resolution if it if it could
be shorter um I don't I don't think that
it takes anything away from the part
that representative Bixby just read if
if it were shortened but uh I just
wanted to say in terms of what a
resolution can can do a resolution that
has no teeth um is that I think this
committee has been
particularly good uh in my time here at
leading the house and demonstrating
bipartisanship and we have on all of
these kind of landfill bills and and I
think that's one of the great virtues of
a house resolution if we can pass this
with significant bipartisan numbers I
think that adds to the strength of this
statement as a statement to our
constituents that it is a case in in
times where we have a lot of partis and
Fishers in the state that this is a real
bipartisan resolution so I I think that
is the value of a house resolution even
when it has no application in law okay
thank
you okay so here's where I am with this
um so where I am with this is I I
certainly would not like to see a
landfill uh permitted next to Forest
Lake State
Park I I I don't I think that's the
wrong place for that kind of
facility my problem is the same as what
representative wheeler had said is that
in general I I don't like to vote for
these house resolutions because at the
end of the day I don't really feel that
they do anything I mean it's okay you
might argue that it's a statement from
the body um but there really is no
I the the what where where the where it
really matters is the policies that this
committee adopts as well as you know
the the other side of the wall if they
go along with it as well but I also I
mean I understand the governor's made a
position on this but as an executive in
the executive branch um they can only
follow what
the law says what statute says it's not
like she she can say well there will
never be a uh a landfill in any
particular place I don't care where it
is what depends on that is what the
rules are and what statutes dictates and
where
Dees uh follows the law and statute and
rules and then determines whether or not
a place is an appropriate place for a
landfill so my problem one of my
problems with this is that um the
statement that the general court
resolves to protect the interests of the
state and its citizens by asking New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services the governor and the Attorney
General to take all appropriate legal
actions that phrase all appropriate
legal
actions I don't know what that means
other than following statute and
following the law um I don't know that
they can just dream up some
other uh way around or a loophole or
whatever but I I don't I don't I have a
problem with that particular line and I
don't know maybe somebody can help me
out with
that as I said I support the fact that I
don't want to see a landfill there but
I'm just really hesitant with the
wording in this house resolution
representative Bixby so um if I
understand you correctly the the phrase
legal actions can be interpreted in a
couple of different ways one is if
you're taking legal action it sounds
like you're suing somebody right the
other is that an action could be legal
which means consistent with all of the
laws and having that in having that
ambiguous phrase in the core of the Crux
of the resolution is problematic so
maybe we can rephrase it
to make it clear that what we are asking
for is them to take all actions that are
uh consistent with uh with current
law okay uh and and that's not the
phrase that I would I don't think that
is is the perfect phrase either I don't
think that that word smithing by
committee is a good idea right but but
the the Gen the the gist is that we want
to make sure that we're not talking
about suing we're talking about uh
making sure that asking them to take
actions that are within the scope of
their legal
parameters but at the same time if I may
I know other people have some comments
but at the same time you know I think it
this doesn't just apply any of the laws
the policies that we've adopted the
rules that Dees has adopted uh does not
just is not just apply to Forest Lake it
applies to any place where um it is
inappropriate to to permit a
landfill and I wanted to be clear about
that representative kto representative
um Howard after thank you madam
chair so my question is are we not
following current
statement representative Howard thank
you madam chair I think we need to
ponder the very real possibility that
this resolution will not pass through
the body of the house and that that
given the current temperature of of our
of that very body it could it could very
well fail and and what kind of statement
would that make so I you know I think
that if if we have any concerns or
doubts that um we should really me
measure take a measure of that
risk representative King I just want to
Second what representative Howard just
said I was going to wait until the very
end but yeah I think that is a real
possibility that we could we could get
it on consent calendar here and then
shoot ourselves in the foot by not
putting it on consent calendar and even
if it does pass the house if it passes
by like three votes that's like w w it
would have been better it would have
been better just to put it on the
consent Calendar use it as a as a media
blitz hey we got on the consent or pass
the house in a bipartisan manner but it
but but it could very easily not be a
bipartisan deal when it goes to the full
house floor and that's going to be
embarrassing in my
opinion questions representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair this
resolution for me as with all things I
will vote my conscience if I voted the
way I thought the house might go or the
Senate might go perhaps I would vote
differently but I don't consider that in
my votes of conscience this is about the
landfill in
Dalton um I think as was said better
than I can by both reps Bixby and ger
this is a statement of where we are as a
legislative body I think it's an
important one and I would like to see us
pass it the idea of it going on
consent um is an interesting one if you
if we feel that it won't be
successful um perhaps consent is the
best way to go thank
you representative
Freeman thank you madam Madam chair um I
wanted to thank you as well as
representative quanta because I was very
ready to vote for this but you brought
up some very compelling points about
this house resolution and and again I
think this is why the legislature needs
to be very um
we need we need to be very careful on
when we put house resolutions in and how
we put them in because it's not meant to
usurp any law that our rule we may put
in it's it's meant to make an
announcement and I just I'm not feeling
comfortable with voting for this after
the points that um yourself and um Vice
chair coma brought up not because I
don't want this to happen but because it
it is a concern I mean a house
resolution most people would not look at
that as a house resolution they would
look at that as a law so I I think we
need to be very careful on how we word
these things and how we proceed forward
with it um I appreciate the sentiment
that all have expressed here about it
and I as well do not want to see
anything happen um with that landfill
but I just think we need to be a little
a little I can't talk I have cold
medicine in me I'm so sorry I I think we
just need to be um a little more choosy
about the words that we put in a
resolution like
this representative King and then ger I
not the sponsor of the bill I'm only a
co-sponsor but I personally would be
totally amenable to reducing the size
and scope of the resolution in order to
be amendable to everybody in here
because I also agree that sometimes you
might have a really good resolution and
you put too much uh flimflam in there
and it just is like a poison pill so I I
I like the idea of everybody being on
board with this resolution and being
happy about it representative ger thank
you madam chair so I just want to
address the the the phrase in question
here about take all appropriate legal
actions because I think that does raise
questions uh as I read that what that
means is to use all of the legal power
all of the powers at your disposal right
so we're urging the governor the
Attorney General etc etc to use all of
the powers at their disposal it's not an
implication that they are not enforcing
current law but it is to again use all
of the powers uh that they have at their
disposal and I don't know in terms of
wording uh representative Bixby was
suggesting the the idea you know if we
say something to the extent of take all
appropriate actions consistent with
existing statute I mean that's different
from legal actions which could have the
implication of lawsuits Etc but I think
that's the meaning of it to take actions
consistent with the existing statute
that are again at the disposal of these
various
agents representative
wheeler just to follow up on what
representative King said I I wonder you
know with the uh Amendment to the legal
action language that you just brought up
which I support could we not just have
this uh lines one through six on page
four be the
resolution with the changes of the legal
um you're asking
[Laughter]
me I mean I I understand that there's a
reason for some wear asses I I'm sure
many of the wear asses would be approved
by everybody here but if there's a few
whereases that are unacceptable then you
know I have no problem getting rid of
those personally but I I I'm not going
to I'm not going to hijack this bill so
representative Bixby yeah um I am
worried that we're about to launch into
trying to write this by committee right
here uh because we're getting into sort
of the details of wording which is much
more uh the task of a subcommittee and I
was wondering if representative king
would be willing to uh take on uh a
drastic reduction of the size of this uh
um uh resolution uh in uh the solid way
subcommittee I'd be fine with that yep
okay that sounds like a plan appreciate
that uh anything else that uh we would
like to discuss in this work session
um
anybody yeah um
so as we have planned this
morning let's see I have planned this
morning that uh we are going
to uh exec two bills
hb21 which is the um prohibiting the
removal of Claws from cats and HB 240
removing the penalty of forfeiture for
non-payment of dog
licenses and um so between now which
we've kind of finished uh discussing
some of the legislation uh that is
before us bills that we have heard in
committee already um we'll take uh take
a break and I think uh it is appropriate
for um both of our sides to uh take some
time to caucus prior to um our exec
sessions and um so I guess we can plan
on coming back here at
11:45 to exec two bills this afternoon
we'll be hearing HB
479 as establishing a committee to study
the use and problems associated with
regulating the distribution and disposal
of certain Solid Waste within landfills
and transfer centers HB 658 raising the
cap on certain reimbursements from the
oil discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
um
hb77 requiring the Department of
Environmental Services to establish a
site specific setback distance for
proposed new landfills and hr10
recognizing the fundamental right to
have clean air clean water and a healthy
environment and so um we will have a uh
a full day ahead of
us um I also would like to pass out some
information that I had received
yesterday of additional information
regarding
hb21 from our friends from the dogs
organization
um so I'm going to pass that out and you
can review it and discuss it in in our
caucuses so I'm gonna pass out let's see
here two three yes U and I'm also uh
Distributing I sent around to the
committee a draft of an amendment to
hb21 uh and so I'll send around the hard
copy now I have two for the clerk again
so the caucuses can discuss the
amendment before our meeting afternoon
great so do you guys have a place that
you can meet
with uh and I guess we can the
Republicans can stay here is that going
to be all right want to do your cus
immediately after this and then um and
then have break orak
have it at like what what's your
pleasure everybody would you like to do
a caucus right after this or you want to
have a little break we'll have a little
break okay so we can have uh you know
sort of like a 10 or 15 minute break and
then uh we can go into caucus okay okay
so um I just wanted to meet briefly with
the folks who are
um who are interested in doing the
amendment on repone approve Bill uh so
but um I need to take five minute three
minute break before we do that so maybe
we could meet uh back in here in about
five minutes and then just talk over
what that amend look like sure so for
purposes of our for purposes of the
Republican caucus why don't we meet back
here at
11:15 and then from 11:15 I'm sorry is
it 11 yeah
11:15 and then from 11:15
to when are we coming back here for
11:45 um we can caucus and then we'll go
into our exec session ises that that
work for everybody okay so we'll see you
here
e
we have all members of Freeman we're
waiting for
okay so we're all here all right no
worries no worries so I'm going to open
up our exec session for HB
FN and do I hear a motion
representative Bixby I would like to
move uh a to ought to pass with
Amendment on uh
2025-the Bixby yes I I think we we've
gone through this uh in work work in in
the uh work session but just want to to
reiterate uh what we heard in uh
testimony was that um essentially uh
Municipal officials need a little bit
more leeway when it comes to issuing a
warrant for uh the um uh enforcing a a
non-payment of a license uh and you
issuing a warrant for the confiscation
of the dog uh and uh what this this
amendment does is it changes the word
shall to May and that leaves uh the
issuing of that warrant at the
discretion of the municipal
official okay thank you uh any any um
discussion about
that seeing
none uh I'd like the uh clerk to call
the role to adopt the amendment for
um
HB
240 Vice chairwoman
comto
yes representative Kenny yes
representative
Penza yes representative
Freeman
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully
yes representative
Barber representative
Miner
yes ranking member
Bixby
yes representative sofikitis
yes representative gerana yes
representative H Haskins
hi representative Howard
yes representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber yes
and chairwoman Aaron
yes total vote is 16 y zero
Nays thank you um with the committee's
permission can we put that on consent
I'm Madam chair oh oh that's right
that's otpa I'm sorry I'm getting ahead
here okay do I hear a a
motion yes I move with I move uh otpa on
2025-the
speak to your motion representative
Bixby I think we're pretty much covered
let's just vote okay uh will the clerk
motion Vice chairwoman coma
yes representative Kenny yes represent
resentative
Penza yes representative Freeman yes
clerk votes
yes representative
Scully yes representative
Barber representative minor
yes ranking member Bixby
yes am I pronouncing your name correctly
representative germana
yes representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
Nays okay with uh the committee's
permission
could we put that on consent yes please
okay and I will write up a committee
report okay thank you very
much all right I'm going to close the
exec on um HB 240 one of our early bills
and I will open up the exec session on
hb21 which is uh removing prohibiting
the removal of cloths from cats and I
move itl on this um Bill Madame chair
I'd like to second that thank you
representative ktoa and I will speak to
my
motion I find this HB 240 um to be a
bill which uh removes the autonomy of
our veterinarians and then dictates to
them what procedures they can and can't
do uh I also see that uh based on
testimony that uh deying of cats is um
not a procedure
that is done in New Hampshire uh by
practice most people when they come to a
veterinarian and they uh request this
kind of procedure the veterinarian will
uh counsel them and talk to them about
not doing this and what other behavior
modification techniques can be used um
and they they have a conversation about
why this is a procedure procedure that
shouldn't be done uh I am not convinced
that this is a problem in New
Hampshire I am seeing um many of these
kinds of bills being introduced all
across the country to see um where it
can get passed where it can't get
passed and um I I think this
is um
a solution looking for a problem we
don't have a problem in New Hampshire
and I I just don't believe that this is
um an appropriate piece of
legislation uh I I think it it creates
overreach into uh the work that our
trusted veterinarians do we heard
testimony from uh veterinarians who
veterinarian who said that uh it's not a
practice that that most veterinarians do
in this state uh it is it is a practice
that has fallen out of um out of
practice uh used to see a lot more of
this in the 1970s 80s 90s you don't see
it uh hardly anymore and I I don't
believe that uh this is uh something
statute that a legislation that uh we
need
to have uh put put into into law so with
that I I am uh very opposed to uh this
Bill thank
you representative Bixby yes
so uh we heard testimony that suggests
that in fact this is uh even though this
is not uh an incredibly common practice
it is a practice that still exists and
uh that it is a practice that is uh not
good for the
and uh I think that um even if uh 95% of
veterinarians do this uh rarely if NE or
or never uh there there might be a small
percentage of who still do it and don't
follow the advice of their National
organizations uh only about a third of
the vets in New Hampshire are members of
the uh New Hampshire veterinarian
Medical Association uh so um I I think
this is something where we do need to um
provide a little bit of statutory
guidance uh for the profession so that
they do follow what uh their profession
generally says is the best idea uh we
however it was uh there need to be some
exceptions for the health of the cat and
also uh for potentially for the health
of cat owners what we have an amendment
that uh brings in that provides that um
that except the possibility of an except
exception if a cat owner needs to have
their cat declawed for medical reasons
uh and we'd like to have a chance to
have that Amendment heard uh so in order
to hear that Amendment we need to turn
vote down the itl so please I'm urging
that folks vote no on the
itl any other comments representative
comp no I I thought I saw your hand okay
um
well again I would I would say that um
either lawmakers trust our veterinarians
to act ethically and in the best
interest of animals and their um and
their owners or we do not and um I just
I just feel that we should itl this bill
so uh with that if there's no further
discussion I would uh ask the clerk to
Vice chair woman
com uh itl it is itl so
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza no representative
Freeman
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully
yes representative Barber
representative minor yes ranking member
Bixby
no Representative sofikitis
no representative German
no representative Haskins
nay representative Howard no
representative wheeler nay
representative Gruber
vote is 8 to8 motion
fails
motion representative German uh Madam
chair I move
d212 do I hear a second I'll second that
do you like to speak to your motion yes
thank you madam chair I'll keep it very
very brief this bill which is or this
amendment which is product of bipartisan
collaboration I want to thank
representative Penza for doing the
research that went into the bill uh it
does two things it Narrows the scope of
the procedure we're talking about so we
are being very specific about the
procedure the procedure of removing the
claw at that first knuckle right so it's
a very specific procedure uh and I would
also point out uh on the second page of
the bill um just personally I would say
that there's there's one part of the
bill I'm not frankly comfortable with uh
and that is the uh section B at line 11
which provides an exception if the cats
Clause POS a significant health risk to
the owner uh the CDC has said that uh
they don't recommend declawing of cats
in that case a reason why I bring that
up is because uh this is a bipartisan
effort to reach a compromise that is
designed to to make the bill as
acceptable to as many members as
possible so uh in that Spirit uh I hope
that we can adopt this amendment to the
bill okay I would like to speak against
this amendment for the following reasons
the fact that um penalties were removed
makes this toothless there is no reason
why you know if somebody does a cat de
claw there's no penalty for it so it
becomes kind of meaningless at all and
the fact that um we
are saying that you can only do a cat
declaw if it's for you know the health
and the benefit of the cat or for the
health and benefit of the owner who may
be on blood thinners or whatever um our
veterinarians already do this and if we
are in this bill already saying that um
um the general court affirms our trust
and licensed New Hampshire veterinarians
expertise compassion and ethical
judgment to make decisions in the best
interest of the animals under their
care well we're not doing that if we're
telling them we're we're Banning
procedures from them and you know they
already do this this this is uh
unnecessary legislation because we
already do this
and that's um why I'll be voting no
against this
comments seeing none I guess I'll call
ask the clerk to call the role on um on
OTP on this
uh adopting the amendment to
hb21 um so go ahead Vice chairwoman
compto no
representative Kenny no representative
Penza yes representative Freeman
no clerk votes
no representative Scully
no representative Barber
no representative Miner
no ranking member Bixby
yes represent representative sofikitis
yes
representative gerana yes representative
H Haskins
I representative Howard yes
representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber yay chairwoman
Aaron
fails well I guess we have a bill here
that is uh or we do we vote okay
just OTP so now the motion is OTP so we
have a vote on that and then because
there's been an interv intervening
motion we can do the itl again
okay um representative gerana thank you
madam chair I move OTP on
hb21 do I hear a
second
second would you like to speak to your
motion uh no thank you I think we've
spoken about this bill L then we know
where we stand so thank you okay um so I
called uh I asked the clerk to call the
role on OTP for
hb21 vice chairwoman ktoa
no representative Kenny no
representative Potenza no representative
Freeman
no clerk votes
no representative
Scully
no representative Barber
no representative Miner
no ranking member Bixby
yes representative sofikitis
yes representative ger
yes representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
wheeler yay representative Gruber yes
vote is 9
fails so I would like to make a motion
hb21 would I hear a second I'll second
that motion I'll second that motion
you um I would speak to my motion but I
believe everything's been said already
so I'll just ask the clerk to call the
role
please motion is itto
okay Vice chairwoman ktoa
yes representative Kenny
yes representative Penza yes
representative Freeman yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully yes
representative Barber yes representative
minor
yes ranking member Bixby
no Representative sofikitis
no Representative gerana no
representative H Haskins nay
representative Howard no representative
wheeler nay representative Gruber nay
chairwoman Aaron yes on
itl votes are 97 motion passes
okay with that I'm going to close the
Oh's oh who's going to do the report um
well I could do the um I will write the
majority report and who will write The
Minority Report representative
ger okay and please uh get the committee
reports into me today if possible I'm
going to close the exec session for
hb21 and we will con reconvene uh at
1:00 for our rest of the afternoon
much
e
[Laughter]
last
care
for a fun weather
day yes
so what under what circumstances would
they
postpone under what circumstances would
they postpone um
almost well no they have on occasion
there are actually rules now there's
there's there's an there is there's a
yeah yeah what committee is he
in
okay oh
fabulous
really
yep that must feel that must feel really
good do yeah yeah okay I'd like members
seats
representan yeah I know she wasn't
feeling
do we have all members present the um
representative Scully there's
representative scul come on
in um representative Penza has left
representative uh fre I mean
representative Freeman has left I'm not
sure about Penza um left for the day you
left and we're waiting for
representative
wheeler he might be late okay I'm going
do
okay okay we are going to get underway
here
um I'm going to open up the hearing for
HB
today is representative
card oh okay is that okay with you uh
yes
so representative parel welcome to
environment Agriculture and you have a
bill for us establishing a committee to
study the use and problems associated
with regulating the distribution and
disposal of certain Solid Waste within
landfills and transfer centers so I'm
here to produce House Bill 479 which
will establish a committee to study the
use and problems associated with
regulating and distribution and disposal
of certain solid ways specifically carry
out single use plastic bags as provided
by many retail outlets that's the actual
focus of the bill plastic bags are used
for an average of 12 minutes but a
single plastic bag has a life expectancy
of up to a thousand years now while I'm
unable to locate a figure for the number
of bags used in New Hampshire Americans
use more than 100 billion plastic bags
each year more than 300 bags per person
per year one could extrapolate that with
a population of 1.4 million ion New
Hampshire uses 4.2 million bags per year
in terms of lost resources to
manufacturer one 100 billion plastic
bags it requires 12 million barrels of
oil that's 12 million barel barrels of
oil unavailable for heating or at the
pump and this is one of things that
obviously drives
inflation now it's generally subn
knowledge that these single use carry
out bags are not food grade uh most of
us know that we can't put our uh
leftover turkey
in these bags most of us know that
wrapping food directly in these bags
allow the chemical leeching of any
number of high-risk Plastics and we
still suffer landfills with these
short-term Plastics that invariably
leech into our water supply if they make
it to the landfill at all we can no
longer otherwise we all live
Downstream report on the adverse health
effects of plastic by the Ecology Center
finds that Plastics typically used in
bottles bags and food containers contain
chemical additives such as endocrine
disruptors which are associated with
negative health effects including Cancer
birth effects and immune system
suppression in humans and
wildli it takes a thousand years for a
plastic bag to degrade into a landfill
unfortunately the bags don't break down
completely but instead photodegrade
becoming microplastics that absorb Toxin
and continue to pollute the environment
this according to a 2020 ACS
Publications on the degreg rates of
plastic in the
environment um
and since Lee hates are uh rightfully
caught our interest a 2019 paper
published in Communications biology is
found that chemical leech hates from
plastic bags impire impair the growth of
fol col
colus
um a marine bacteria that provides
1110th of the world's
oxygen during the 2011 International
Coastal cleanup volunteers collected
12,450 lb of bags in the United States
and Massachusettes alone Clean Sweep
volunteers collected 5,712 pounds of
plastic bags the most common found of
lit of most common form of litter found
in the ocean these plastic bags break
down small Plankton siiz particles that
can outnumber Plankton 6 to1 and these
particles collect toxins like pcbs and
DDT at levels up to a million times the
level found in and
seawater now we'll be hearing further
testimony you can elaborate the
environmental Lisk even greater detail
and if you would like a copy of the
links that are underlined in electronic
form I should add this also I'll be glad
to share an electronic uh version of My
Testimony where you can actually the
links are active I'll make sure to do
that yes we would like that copy thank
you could I just send that to you for
distribution huh could I send it to you
for distribution you may but uh the copy
that you have you can give to the clerk
today if you
like oh okay okay I would say that you I
I would give you an electronic copy
where you can actually click on the link
and okay I'll send to the committee okay
good enough we'll see if that works okay
um we'll be hearing further testimony
that can elaborate the environmental
risk to even greater detail but I
believe most of us recognize the health
threats if not specific details now why
am I asking for a study committee when
for one there's nothing to prevent me
from drafting legislation and two we
know that study committees are not in
favor of the current house
leadership I have seen successful
legislation in all the other New England
states while New Hampshire languishes on
the back there's a map of uh which
states have passed bag
bands
um more than a good
bill we what we really need address is
legislation that will find its way to
the Senate and to the governor's desk we
need cons consensus on this as we had in
2019 uh a study committee even Limited
in scope will be better prepared to
create such legislation than any one
legislator and I'm aware it's not a
popular time yes word study committee I
will ask for the sake of all New
Hampshire citizens that cherish our
precious environment to break with
procedure and Grant this request and I
thank for your time and I will answer
any questions thank you representative
parall any questions from the committee
representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for being here today and
presenting this um why do we need to
establish Lish this particular committee
when we have the solid waste working
group because to my knowledge and I I
will gladly be corrected but to my
knowledge Solid Waste working group is
not uh working on originating any
legislation around a single use plastic
bag ban at this
time I would I would I would love to be
corrected if I'm wrong uh it is
something that we are looking into uh we
have been if I may um follow up on that
I we are looking at uh Plastics
recycling plastic bands uh anything to
keep things out of landfills that's our
charge is a landfill reduction uh we
have goals which we are working on uh
you know to in terms of you know what
kinds of legislation we have been
interviewing uh various people from
various organizations in other states
and how they handle these different
things
um so plastic bags is is uh something
that we're we have on our plate that
we're looking at as well as you know
mattresses textiles all these different
kinds of things so um it
is uh in our in our window of things
that we are wanting to work
on um but what I what I am seeing here
in particular is that um you're not see
seeking to examine Plastics per se you
just mentioned certain Solid Waste
within landfills and transfer centers
so you know in terms of a if you really
want to do a committee to study
specifically Plastics I I would imagine
that that's something that would need to
be refined yes could I add that my
original um my original uh uh bill sent
out uh language sent to LCR did not talk
about the distribution and disposal of
certain solid ways I did say single use
plastic bags is provided by many retail
outlets that's what I sent in okay and
uh they seem to be insistent that they
didn't want to use that terminology I'm
very sorry they didn't um May I turn
this around and ask a question
of me yes sure go right ahead okay sure
Ian a friendly question no no no no okay
even if it's unfriendly I'm good
it's friendly here for the same reason
you know um but um do you think that
something like this a plastic bag ban we
had we almost I wasn't here in 2019 but
I understand that we were very very
close to getting this ban and the rest
of our Northeast has already taken the
step we're lagging behind we have a real
problem here do you think it might help
alleviate the important work that the
swag does if we were to set this up as a
separate committee possibly yeah I don't
know I mean I and that's something I
think I probably want to discuss with
representative eel MH and see you know
in terms of uh priority what what the
solid waste working group uh wants to
hone in on for
2025 um I know we're looking we've got
the uh paint recycling bill that we've
trying to get through the house and
hopefully through the Senate um and then
I know that you know we've looked at
we've done the electronic waste we're
looking at
um like I said textiles and mattresses
which you know kind of big things big
bulky things uh so yeah but in terms of
like priorities or what we're studying
but I do know that you know we have
members on the solid waste working group
that are dealing with uh Plastics
Recycling and it and it is an issue for
um the trash haulers and also um the the
waste facilities in deal dealing with
all the Plastics and you know from a
posos standpoint too um it's it's a
contributing factor for for the uh
contamination
contaminants so I would not see this
bill as being contrary to anything that
the swag is doing no yeah no okay uh
representative Scully you had a question
oh thank you Madame chair and thank you
for your testimony I I think you're
basically covered it my concern was the
emphasis of your testimony was Plastics
and yet that is not mentioned anywhere
in the legislation so there would be no
guarantee that this commission would
take that issue up to the extent that
you would wish it to since it's not
specifically mandated to do
so can I make that a question I'm sorry
can I make that a question and answer
would you
agree yes uh um I would agree and I
would also welcome an amendment that
actually specifies in no disputable
language that this is dealing with
single use care out plastic bags as
subed by retail outlets we're not going
to get into the plastic bags that you I
mean there there's a lot of territory
with this and I think it does need to be
more specific and I felt like they you
know I mean I I felt like that the
legislation as it came back to me was
less specific so I would agree with you
yes representative Gruber thank you
madam chair uh thank you for bringing
this issue forward about Plastics is
clearly um a serious issue you uh would
you be supportive open to the idea if
the plast if the solid waste working
group said yes we'd like to take this on
uh more specificity of obviously rather
than creating another committee here um
seems to me that the uh Solway working
group is quite knowledgeable and have
broad representation and I would presume
hopefully a lot of clout what what they
that I would be balance that because
there is a lot of institutional
knowledge within Solid Waste working
group
um with the with the concept
that right now we have constituents who
are crying for Relief on this one we
have constituents that are crying for
Relief there's a and petition circulated
you will hear some results of that later
in the
testimony um I believe there's an immed
immediacy to this that might be F might
be more directly addressed by a study
committee study committee
yes okay thank you representative ger
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question good to see you U so
I have one question and then if I'm
allowed a follow-up question uh the
first question is um the subcommittee
the study committee would be able to ask
the solid waste working group to come to
some meetings and help provide some of
that input to the work of the group
correct I understand that's the function
of a committee is to solicit testimony
thank you and may I follow up follow up
of course thank you so as I understand
these single-use plastic bag bands have
kind of mixed history in terms of of
success so I'm just wondering if you
could give us a sense
of why some things work and and some
things don't why do some bands not work
very well and what has has proven
successful I can't say where I've seen
them having mixed excess of plastic bag
band I know that similar legislation
sometimes does Fall by the wayside after
it's passed but um I'm when I travel in
New York state I I see a state that's
that native to me once littered with a
whole bunch of plastic plags stuck in
trees and blowing in the wind now um
when I go to the grocery store there
it's a bag free zone plastic bag free
zone um I have to imagine I have not
been under their landfills but I have
mentioned has an effect Downstream which
is what we're really trying to affect
um in Vermont the same issue and and in
my visit to main I I've
seen firsthand results of what these bag
bands do and I I see it would be highly
effective thank you okay any other
questions for representative paral see
none thank you very much for coming and
introducing this bill to us and thank
you
okay yeah um I call Susan
Richmond and you've requested four
minutes oh yeah I need your pink slip uh
representative
parial bring it
up you go so Madam chair and members of
the environment and agriculture
committee thank you for taking my test
I'm Susan Richmond resident of Durham
I'm on the Durham uh citizen advisory
committee to our Solid Waste uh
committee and I'm also one of the
founding members of New Hampshire
network and on the steering committee
New Hampshire network is four years old
and it was just founded by number of
people from
various environmental groups in
different towns realizing that we all
were asking the same questions and
wondering how to respond to what we
viewed as concerns and or energy
committees what's going on how can we
help our towns and by working together
we've made it a little bit easier for
people to know what is the best way to
participate in uh New Hampshire
government in terms of sustainability we
are all volunteers and the reason I'm
telling you about New Hampshire network
is we have put together a petition which
I'll talk about in one minute but to
answer um representative Jana's question
um bag bills that have not been
successful have either allowed the
stores to say oh you don't want
single-use plastic we'll give you a
thicker plastic which
then customers still use as single use
and throw away so that there is net more
plastic being thrown away than otherwise
or places where perhaps it was just the
preference of the the individual grocery
store and not um the bill they chose not
to charge 5 cents 10 cents for whatever
kind of bag they gave and then people
also were not responsive but in the
places where bills were changed to make
sure that there was some kind of fee to
get a bag and where they made sure that
the alternate bags were not just more
throwaway plastic in some cases they
specified you know it could be a strong
plastic bag if it had a stitched handle
but when they specified that these these
bills have been successful um and and
again if you wanted we could get you
examples of that okay so I'm going to
start out by um I email this to you I
had I must um say that we are not
allowed to use props in the committee
rooms oh I'm sorry okay no no so I mean
if you if you uh emailed us the charts I
did I did okay so that's sufficient um
but you can speak to the data that okay
so uh plastic kind of got household use
in 1950 and then I need to G G by uh for
the period 2000 to 220 it had an
increase of about 56% so that takes us
to there it is forecast to
increase uh
1003 no it has increased 130 fold and it
is expected to Triple Again by
2060 so your plastic production it kind
of looks like the um heat emissions the
carbon dioxide emission the hockey
hockey stick graph that they talk about
you know so plastic is kind of smooth
and then suddenly wow and that's part of
the reason why we're getting so much
information just now about how toxic
plastic is oh forgot to hand these out
so these are my handouts um they are
clipped together because the bottom
section is from some health
professionals and it's like really since
2020 that they are
discovering that patients with dementia
when they can look at their brains
postmortem had 50% more plastic in them
and there's an incidence of um you know
increased incidence in them so the use
of plastic is increasing the effect of
plastic is increasing and our
understanding of it is and if it seems
like why now it's because we're really
just coming to full grips with it so let
okay so uh New Hampshire network has a
plastic working group and um I'd never
thought about plastic one way or the
other but I've been learning and we
discovered in our discussions that
Jaffrey New London
Tamworth Durham we all were having
discussions with representatives of
major grocery chains in most cases it's
it's hanford's that they've been the
most um available and those
Representatives say you're right we
would like to stop giving these out we
have sustainability goals those include
Health we know these plastic bags are
not healthy but if we stop our customers
will go to our competitors we can't stop
unless there's a Level Playing Field we
can't stop unless there is legislation
requiring us to do this as has happened
in Maine Massachusetts Vermont other New
England states meanwhile the legislature
last year said oh we're not really sure
if people want this and it may be that
the grocery chains don't want it this
cost the grocery stores money you know
four to five cents a bag times maybe a
thousand bags in a day it mounts up
pretty quickly so instead of each of
these different towns trying to talk to
to the grocery store separately and
Jaffrey and uh Tamworth together got 400
signatures just in the last year on a on
petitions they had done separately
instead of doing this town by Town New
Hampshire Network said let's work on
this Statewide and see if that gives us
a little more uh you know we get heard
and we are hoping we've only had a
petition out for half a month and we've
garnered 200 no uh online about 255
signatures when I last looked but paper
petitions another
150 we're in this for the Long Haul so
you know we really hope that you the
legislators will help speed it up
because I know Solid Waste working group
has just a huge responsibility but we're
also hoping to take our work to the
grocery chains to the executives and
bring our petitions to churches rotaries
Community groups um and get far more
signatures we're just really starting
out and that's like after the holiday
season so we were hampered
um so that is where we are with yeah so
we feel that there's sort of a chicken
egg that you know the grocery stores say
go to the legislature legislator says go
to the grocery store can we be the
brokers in standing for citizens who are
across the state um I gave you more
information about the evils of plastic
the main thing that I want to point out
is that it is really toxic when it is
being created you know that's your
cancer alley um but it also in being end
of life a large amount of it is being um
incinerated so that's off gassing bad
stuff or if it is being so-called
recycled there's off gassing in that
process and recycled plastic usually
only lasts one or two more times before
it is too degraded and then of course
we' heard about how it it does instead
of um just becoming part of the in uh
becoming null it becomes smaller
particles small enough to pass through
cell barriers and that is how they enter
the animals we eat our bodies and
there's more we do not have the
technology to remove the 11 uh Bill
million metric tons of plastic pollution
that are on the ocean floor okay so I
think I have said enough any questions
thank you um so I'm I'm wondering if any
of the research or findings if you can
share that with representative EO from
the solid waste working group so that uh
we can use that as part of our
discussions when we meet we meet on a
monthly basis I know and I keep trying
to get to them and um um because you
know that again as I said before a solid
waste working group is looking to reduce
uh what we landfill right Plastics is a
part of that reduction and um gosh I
remember you know I I I was of the the
time when everything was in paper bags
yes and um then when when folks decided
that paper bags was uh bad for the
environment because it involved cutting
down trees uh we all went to plastic so
here we are again now we're looking
plastic is not good maybe we ought to be
going back to paper so here we are turn
a circle anyway any other questions
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair and thank you for your testimony
on this very important topic how will
consumers handle the extra expense if
they're not given free plastic bags
right well stores are in the business of
making money giving products and
probably they are paying for it in
slightly elevated prices of products
which is in that is invisible but to get
solid you know bags that last longer you
can get them for as little as a dollar
and is you know if you want organic
cotton then we're talking about a lot
more but you also have your basic
cardboard box and you know grocery
stores get their goods in boxes they
have boxes Aldi has a little corner
where you help yourself to boxes and I
believe Market Basket deas used to do
that as well so that is not so terrible
and
our bread still comes in plastic so you
can put your dog poop in that when I was
a teenager I collected it in a paper bag
with a paper towel that was my family
task um but
so if what people will have to pay for a
couple solid bags is not outsized and
then they last forever but one of the
ways that some bills have been
structured has been if you're on Snap or
Wick you don't have to pay we're going
to just give you the bags so that's
another option so again you know fig
figured out yeah I'm sorry
representative
Bixby yeah so um I uh I happen to be
looking at is either the New York Times
or Washington Post in the last couple of
days and there was an article about um
how microplastics are going across the
blood brain barrier did you happen to
run across the that and is that
referenced in any of your yeah uhhuh um
the so I've clipped together my two
pages three p my two pages is clipped to
a onepage double-sided that is medical
information from an OBGYN about how
plastic is found in the placenta where
it um is harmful to a
baby's uh growth and organs another and
and that has I I think just one
reference to it but again Ask me and
I'll I'll get some more from an
OBGYN who does research and and has been
given me this information then there's
another paragraph referring to it was
Washington Post but I think it was
reporting on an article in nature just
from the last couple days about how um
plastic is affecting mental capacity and
and you know I guess being fatal if it's
it's increasing dementia and uh I've Got
The Source on that and then finally a
longer article from New Hampshire
Healthy climate um none of those members
could be here today but they gave me an
article about plastic harming other um
organs of the body and that is part of
uh the packet of really just visuals
that I've sent you okay any other
questions seeing none thank you I had
somewhat it's it's not strictly it's
just a different question so um you may
ask a different question uh so
uh there's and I think you kind of
alluded to this already but people often
will use plastic bags that they get for
free at the grocery store for a number
of different things like um you know
handing off a sweater they want mended
to a friend or uh picking up the dog
waste as he references referenced or you
being a like liner for other trash cans
uh how is is is the loss of that going
to be problematic well people will take
it as that
but you know turning we're all talking
about how wonderful Jimmy Carter is
people weren't very happy when he said
put on a sweater when you're cold so um
you know we we need to give give up a
little bit on this I can give my friend
a sweater without a plastic bag that it
is not the responsibility of the food
purveyor to provide me for free so I'm
not being sympathetic I am sorry
okay seeing no other questions thank you
very much for Testimony um so I I do
want to remind everybody and I you know
just in the interest of time to um I
think we all recognize the that it's
problematic to have all these Plastics
in our landfill I think we can all agree
on
that um so and and this bill itself is
just calling for a study committee um on
um osal of certain solid waste it
doesn't
necessarily uh mean just
Plastics and or you know single-use
plastic bags so I just want to remind
people you know to to stay on um on
message with with establishing a study
committee as opposed to
um explaining U the dangers of Plastics
in our life and everything because I
think we all understand that so uh with
that I would call Cynthia Walter who has
minutes so just tell us why you think
it's a good idea or not a good idea to
have a study
committee right I hello I'm Cynthia
Walter
sorry I try my hearing aids um so I'd
like to get you hand hand that around
please if you could as quickly thank you
so I'm Cynthia Walter 22 West conquer
Street in Dover I'm also the co-chair of
the do plastic production group and I'm
not going to talk specifically about
plastic harm I'm going to talk about the
economic aspects of why this bill is
needed at this time and why the study
committee is needed at this time now I
have read um I think I oh gee I think I
may have typed it in the wrong way this
is the first page that you're you should
be looking at is actually says February
3rd on the beginning I was in a hurry to
stample things um so if you turn over
your page to look for February 3rd on
the top um you'll see we have an urgent
need and we have to reduce our taxpayer
cost for municipal waste that's why we
can't wait um we also must accelerate
our actions we can't wait to get to 25%
cut in by 2050 and third the wonderful
the wonderful Solid Waste working group
and the terrific Solid Waste Management
plan is horrific but that working group
is working so hard but when I read that
25-page document I tallied up only using
five of the goals five of the eight
goals I tallied up 120 I have them
written down 120 distinctive initiatives
in that plan now at a meeting rate of
once per month that is 10 years of
meetings
so I'm trying to make the case that if
this study committee could focus on
something straightforward and simple
that is a no cost solution to a very
costly problem you'll see my statistics
on the and the numbers on the municipal
cost that are we were paying right now
if the stat study committee could focus
on very targeted legislation that
everyone will agree on
bipartisan from do that from May until J
August write the report get the
legislation put forward we pass it now
our municipalities will pay less for so
many of the things that they're now
paying extra for and increasing so
that's why I'm saying the study working
group is doing great but they cannot
work fast enough on all those things
this one particular topic is the no cost
easy loow hanging fruit so if you look
on my my option one that says on your
first page then if you flip over to that
you'll see the other compelling reasons
why we need to work quickly on this it's
just been found out that these plastic
bags which children are touching and
eating and storing food and and holding
food and everything else contains um
toxics that impair their development it
leads to harm um and and Lead so we're
dealing with a compelling substance that
we could remove from children's hands
from Suffocation risks and so on we can
quickly get rid of that so I'm saying
it's a matter of speed here it's not the
intens it's not the scope of the problem
it's the speed that we need to address
it and this one study committee can
focus laser on that topic also um if you
go down to the end you know you'll see
the costs are huge we're paying millions
of we have two million pounds now we're
dumping 20 65 million pounds in grocery
bags every year if we put that bill out
65 million pounds of grocery plastic
bags will not be in our landfills
immediately so the speed really makes
the difference um they're costing our
our bills with our Waste Management
Services are going up by 50,000 or more
dollars every unit every time we we try
to contract with somebody and why
because those stupid plastic bags are
tangling up the equipment and requiring
huge shutdown times so our bills are
going up which means our taxes are going
up because that's how we pay for our our
waste handling so I mean the speed at
which this committee could deliver this
solution is so important for our tax
reduction and and TOA here's another one
this is amazing DOA right now every year
pays um more pays 350 ,000 to dispose of
contaminated plastic contaminated
recycling waste because it's
contaminated mostly with grocery bags so
we're hauling this stuff at
$350,000 a year we will have cleaner
recycling bins immediately if we don't
have plastic bags rolling out of the
grocery stores so I'm saying we're doing
thousands thousands of dollars and
millions of pounds of waste right away
and many children living safer at home
because we won't have those plastic bags
and I'm sorry but the the solid waste
working group you just have so much on
your plate that that you couldn't work
quite as fast as this committee could
work does that
help thank you and I'm glad that you uh
you included the New Hampshire Solid
Waste Management plan where it does show
that landfilling is our last
resort um and that um you know yes we
have um 120 distinct initiatives we are
not tackling them um um you know one
after another serially they are we are
looking at multiple ones different I
mean we got Dees working on some things
we've got uh H uh the New Hampshire uh
recovery recycling Association looking
at some things so we have several people
who are doing different things which is
why I am thinking that all of the
research that you and your organizations
and all of you folks who have come to
testify uh have have come equipped with
and knowledgeable of if that information
is shared with solid waste working group
that cuts out the time that we need to
do the research you have that
information you can say you know here's
all the information that we have in what
other states are doing what other towns
are doing and so and so forth and um
these are
recommendations that would be that that
you guys have been the study committee
you're doing all the work so just share
your results with solid waste working
group I think um would you think that
that would be a good
idea well again I'm only a citizen and
I'm only a retired teacher and so I I
don't know how legislation gets
worded so and processed so that all the
stakeholders and all the opposition is
just hand is
considered as the legislation is doing
so far living five years in in in New
Hampshire now I'm very impressed with
how engaged all of you folks are I'm I'm
astounded that you're all here and
you're doing all this wonderful work for
just travel money but anyway so here's
my concern about that the solid waste
working group group may not have the
time between now and August September
when this report would be written by a
working group Sorry by a study committee
you may not have the time between now
and then to actually fine-tune
legislation engage stakeholders make
sure the grocery stores are all on board
the the the the documents written
exactly as it should be and then the
bill will go into the whatever happens
in in in the mill um in the fall and
then that bill will be will be hray and
um passed by partisan and signed by the
governor by Next by this coming June um
a year from now I don't know if if you
have other pressing needs like you
talked about electronic waste which is
so toxic and you talked about all those
other things you have other more
pressing things so maybe you wouldn't
have the time I agree you have the
capacity and the interest to do it but I
don't know if you have the time to
fine-tune that legislation to make sure
it's ready to roll
exactly without opposition and the
stakeholders have been heard and have
been
addressed that's the advantage of having
one group doing one thing I agree you're
I know you're not doing 120 things one
unit at a time but I just thought it was
kind of amusing that it was so big a
list um so that's my only comeback on
that and I again I'm not a legislator
but I would like to see this bill get
done perfectly ready and signed by next
June so we don't have all those toxins
in our children's hands we don't have
that 65 million pounds going dumping
into our Landfield every year we don't
have those extra thousands that I talked
about um um that I'm paying in my taxes
okay thank you representative Bixby so
um if we were to uh consult with uh
representative eel who is the chair of
the solid waste working group about
whether this would be the more efficient
way to get to the right point or uh if
in fact having moving it up the priority
listed the solid wayte working group
would be more efficient would you be
happy with whichever solution as long as
it got got got it there faster
you representative evil is is amazing so
yes you all are amazing so I think your
advice definitely I definitely bow to
your advice I I
know chemicals and insects and streams I
do not know legislation that's your
expertise you can decide which is the
better way to get this done I see now
that you really want to get it done and
we will get it done one way or another
we're going to see that bill in um um
June of 26 yay yes represent hkin thank
you madam chair and thank you for coming
to testify with us today would you agree
that part of the urgency is that some of
our grocery stores are ask ask in us as
consumers when we buy meat that's pla
that's wrapped in plastic if we want it
in yet an additional plastic bag does
that in your opinion add to the urgency
of the need for the study
committee I couldn't address the issue
of packaging meat um that's see that's
exactly an example of the kind of carve
out we might have to have that the
stores would have to say but we should
be allowed to do this we were talking
about plastic bags at the checkout and
so that's exactly the kind of detail for
safety reasons um sanitation reasons or
com Comm customer Comfort reasons that
we would have to address um so that we
sure we don't you know leave somebody in
in in the in the out of the loop um and
that's why that's another you you just
raise a point that's why the study
commit could hear about from The
Butchers and say Here's here's what The
Butchers need to have to make sure they
can have their needs and their customers
needs met thank you any other questions
representative sofikitis
um thanks for coming um don't ever say
again um you're only a teacher because
it's like oh you're just a mother
whatever because I'm just a State Rep
yeah
we have a Citizens
legislature and um so I would just ask
you have you ever thought about running
for public
office
okay than you very I'm gonna have to ask
to stick to the uh to the bill here it's
part of studying yeah appreciate it any
other questions representative guber uh
just quickly um clearly your goal is a
strategic plan to get something next
fall as a bill yes um and you need all
these resources and the question I have
that's been brought up a number of times
you're already doing a lot of the work
but um and representative EO and and
cration working group I don't know if
this Committee of five who don't
necessarily know anything would actually
accelerate things or slow things down um
what do you thought about this because
we have you want to get people who have
working who are committed to looking at
what needs to be done and not bring new
people in necessarily so my concern what
you thought about that because five
people that are just appointed May who
knows well I I did happen to attend a
couple of sessions in another study
group another study uh committee not a
study group I don't know terminology but
a study committee and what what I was
impressed about is it's the the
combination of having the study
committee focused on one topic right so
they can use the information that's
already been garnered as you said by the
uh um um study working group in looking
at the bigger pictures and looking at
some of the knowing the list of
stakeholders and so on but then the
study committee can take the
stakeholders that the study group said I
identified are important and here's the
extra part they can take the people who
know how to write
legislation such that it is trouble free
who know how to consider things like the
The Butcher and so on and put that into
it and so I think it's a matter of
getting those different perspectives Al
together on one topic so I agree they've
the study working group has a lot of
study time on so many topics but their
expertise can be part of the picture
it's necessary but not sufficient okay
well thank you very much I really
now yeah I've got four cards left and
we're running out of we've run out of
time ready but I thank you very M very
much Miss Walter for coming and speaking
with us this afternoon um I call
Christine babber and again if if you've
heard something already that
you've uh been thinking of saying please
don't repeat it appreciate
it uh from do plastic reduction group th
thank you for hearing my testimony and I
will try not to repeat anything um it
it's very encouraging to hear the the
discussion and the questions um my name
is Christine babber and I am co-chair of
the Dover plastic reduction group so I
am speaking in support of this bill and
I will try to um focus on the Bill and
that give um information on plastic that
you have already
heard um the the solid waste that our
group is seeking to reduce is of course
Plastics which is why I will be focused
on Plastics um Plastics according to the
US Environmental Protection Agency are
the second largest contributor to
Municipal Solid Waste
18.5% the
2022 New Hampshire Solid Waste
Management plan has one of its
overarching themes reducing and
diverting waste So the plan states that
efforts should focus on high volume and
weight material
as well as single use products and
packaging so I think one of the reasons
why you've heard so much Focus um on on
single-use plastic bags in addition to
uh representative parshall's uh
explanation is that they would be one of
the easiest single-use products that
could be considered for reduction in New
Hampshire they are distributed in huge
quantities in grocery stores and there
are actually easy reusable
Alternatives so uh I think um you know
again to give some sense of the um the
size of this issue Americans use an
average of
365 plastic bags per per person per year
and the average working life of those
minutes according to the American
Chemical Society studies on plastic
degradation estimate it could take
anywhere from 300 to a, years for these
bags to break down uh depending on the
environment the temperature tempature
microbial loading uh size and shape of
the sample Etc so they not only uh fill
our landfills but also last for a really
long time so again the focus on that I
am very proud that dover's Recycling and
Waste Management Programs mission
statement names reduction first among
methods to efficient
manage and implement the recycling and
waste management programs of the city um
I I used an environment America research
and policy centers single use plastic
bag waste reduction calculator to
estimate the impact eliminating
single-use plastic bags in Dover would
have in one year and you can run this
for your own community Community there
would
be
9,891 th000 fewer single use plastic
bags to pollute our environment in do
1,717 miles laid Side by
Side in New
Hampshire the single-use plastic bags
eliminated by a typical Statewide policy
eliminating these bags would be
m988 th000 laid side by side okay excuse
me I'm I'm going to have to stop you
okay um because while I appreciate you
know a lot of the information here about
um why we ought to ban plastic bag
single-use PL plastic bags that's
actually not the bill that we're talking
about this would be absolutely um
perfect testimony if we had a bill
before us that actually did ban plastic
bags but we what we're talking about is
whether or not we want to have a study
committee to
investigate um disposal of certain Solid
Waste within landfills and um I I just
wanted to stay on track with that and
okay even though I I I do appreciate all
your research and information which is
valid um I I just wanted to let you know
that okay thank you so I I do support
this bill and I agree with the urgency
that has been expressed by previous um
speakers and um want also to offer the
expertise the um research anything that
we can offer to either a study committee
or the solid waste working group um you
know and I and I believe that
representative bixby's suggestion is a
good one um for for everyone to consider
okay thank you so thank you sure any
questions uh you have written testimony
you can share with us okay can you pass
it up so that we can have that for the
clerk um I'm going to ask Ann pod pod Li
I'm sorry
Podi good afternoon yes my name is an
pod lipney I was going to read the
testimony of a plastic engineer named
Mark Barry who could not be here today
but I'm not going to given your
recommendation to stick to uh the
subject so I do support this bill I am a
member of the New Hampshire Network
Plastics working group and my little
piece it won't take but a minute I am
one of those folks who went out to seek
petitions on the plastic uh on banning
plastic uh bags and in a matter of 3
hours I easily got 60 petitions it
seemed to me as if the public is
absolutely aware that recycling is no
longer working and is not the right
answer to this problem I really felt
that people were waiting for a bill like
this I mean for a petition like this to
come into their hands so they could sign
it any argument that came to me was
easily refuted um by people understood
when they said oh you know uh what will
I do with my pet waste and a good answer
was given they were immediately able to
sort of reconfigure that answer and and
actually accept it as opposed to
remaining stubborn and oppositional so I
my point is simply that people know that
right now in this day and age recycling
is not the answer they know that plastic
is either buried burned or borne out to
sea they don't want it and I think that
the time is ripe right now and people
are really paying attention so I think
this would be an excellent idea to push
forward thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming today thank you uh Ray
speak again please let us know whether
you think it's a good idea or not to to
establish a study committee okay I'm
going to do that uh Ray reslin uh I'm
just a citizen uh I'm learning like
everyone else I think there's a lot of
good things that have been uh brought
forward uh today uh and uh as far as uh
be uh wanting to be approv or against it
uh I think that's something you folk
have to decide uh look uh this thing
about uh plastic bags which I don't see
even in this uh Bill uh which I don't
understand why it's not in there if
that's what your focus is going to be uh
but it is a problem plastic bags are a
problem uh definitely uh do need to be
dealt with and uh they do not need to go
to a landfill because they don't break
down I I think you'll probably find that
most plastic bags uh after the uh
unfortunately have to be separated uh
because most of it goes down to Bill R
to be separated ated uh that Mo most of
those plastic bags become a source of
energy and probably get burnt at a uh
waste to energy plant uh probably right
here in conquer uh but uh all of this is
extremely important all of this with uh
hazardous waste or any kind of waste uh
recycle is really important and your
working group uh with with all you have
to do uh uh try trying to do good work
and I'm sure you are uh in regards to uh
the other folks that have uh spoken here
today uh I think uh they they they are
paying attention they are very good and
I think uh they are willing to volunteer
their time uh to put into this to do the
studies and come back and work with you
folks uh to uh make some good progress
in this but this whole thing with waste
and plastic and so forth and
unfortunately
uh I don't want to get off topic here
but some of that is coming from out of
state and and we got to deal with it
including plastic bags by the way and
and so it's a big issue I don't want to
take any more time because you got a lot
to do and uh I certainly have nothing
against a committee I'm not sure exactly
how that's established but obviously
there are some people here that are
concerned with this and I I think would
be willing to work with you folks uh to
get stuff done okay that's all I got to
say thank you very much any questions oh
nope you're all good thank you very much
appreciate you coming today our last uh
pink card is uh John Tut Hill from my
Hill U thank you chairman Aaron U
members of the committee nice to see you
all I will be very quick uh and I will
not mention any
hydrocarbons although I do have concerns
about additive stabilizers and uh
tolerance
um I like this bill as presented um and
I would support the more General
approach and I strongly support uh
establishing the study committee and not
relying on the working group in the 80s
the environmental councils were formed
and part of their mandate was to uh do
public education and to advise the
commissioner of the Department of envir
enal services on
policy on waste policy specifically for
the waste management
Council um for almost decades really
there were about five or six words which
dictated all discussion and
consideration of solid waste matters in
the state of New Hampshire one was the
interstate commerce clause and the other
was we have a landfill capacity crisis
and that was pretty much the end of the
discussion uh the waste management
Council was essentially silent
um a lot of vacancies particularly on
the public interest side industry was
heavily represented
um the solid waste working group
actually came out of a small study
committee I believe of three members and
they really changed the Paradigm that
study committee of three people Karen
able I believe chairing um allowed us to
open up the conversation and that was
several years ago and we're still here
and we're in a moment of opportunity
right now to really make some some
important changes in New Hampshire so uh
the working group I've been really
pleased with what they've done I try to
attend remotely when I can uh it's
fascinating watching Regulators the
regulated community and legislators um
conversing but again um I would prefer
to have a legislative study committee
not a commission that's a big deal um
but I think a a study committee or a
subcommittee of the ENA committee could
be very useful right now and I would
like to see it focused a little more
generally in fact I very much like the
language uh in this bill as presented
and I think it could again be a
breakpoint to move us to a new a new
phase um one last thing and then I will
let you move on to your next bill uh in
2011 a commission actually uh prepared a
comprehensive report on construction and
demolition debris that's a big issue in
Sullivan County right now um and this
bill would allow us to talk about some
of the things that need to happen before
New Hampshire continues to move forward
with how they are going to manage
construction and demolition debris the
2011 commission came up with some
excellent recommendations some of them
have been implemented some have not but
they changed the marketplace in New
Hampshire and on the Eastern side of the
state um private investment sort of
brought us into the 20th century maybe
into the beginning of the 21st century
and they really through economic incent
Ives are doing things much much better
than what we used to be doing which was
just mixed loads Mass waste um
contamination was a real problem um so
the management is getting better and it
needs we need to continue doing that so
I would like to submit into the record a
copy of that 2011 report and I will
submit an electronic link for the entire
committee but I thank you appreciate
that pass this for the uh clerk okay any
questions I bring it to you or just pass
it
thank
you thank you for coming today Mr tidle
and we have one last pink card could you
please and please introduce yourself for
the
record for the record my name is Peter
Schmidt I represent over W one uh which
is Trafford 19
um and and I can be very brief I
actually served on this committee 20
years ago um and I'm aware of the fact
that that you are currently wrestling
with a number of very significant issues
uh I I know many of you not all of you
but I know many of you and I know that
there's a lot of uh willingness and
Readiness to uh attack these very
important issues and this is one of
them uh it without a doubt and you
should not be deterred by the fact that
the bill does not specify which one of
the certain uh materials uh you should
study uh that is the fault of the
drafters that they did not uh adhere to
the request of the sponsor to be more
specific but in any case this bill is a
vehicle that you can use in any way you
see fit in this General topic and this
is uh one of the most serious aspects so
have at it um this this study bill gives
you the option to look into things that
the sponsors may not have been aware
that you're currently dealing with but
there there's a lot of intellect in on
this Committee just among the people I
know and I'm sure the others are also
equally gifted in terms of dealing with
these serious
issues uh because that's that's the
reality this these plastic bags are only
the the one we've talked about most in
this particular hearing but uh but it is
something that is not sufficiently
understood we we are only beginning to
grasp the the depth of U of the the
problem that that plastic bags and their
disposal represent so please uh have at
it as I say thank you very much I'll
answer any questions you may have thank
you appreciate it any questions from the
committee seeing none I made myself
clear
yeah as you usually
do uh and I don't see any other pink
cards may I have the blue sheet uh I see
on the uh online portal we have 148
people supporting this bill and uh three
14 148 in support and three in
opposition and for meeting the folks a
couple of the people who wrote in
opposition were saying that the uh Focus
was too
broad so but anyway um we have one
person who signed in support on the blue
sheet with that I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 479 I want to thank
everybody who's come out to speak to us
today about this this
bill we are now going to move on to HB
658 raising the cap on certain
reimbursements from the oil discharge
and Disposal cleanup
fund and let me see I don't know who
is 658 uh do we have representative
Edgar there you go representative Edgar
welcome to environment and agriculture
committee and would you
please uh introduce this bill to us very
good uh uh thank you madam chairman yes
um I I'm here to introduce it and say a
few words and uh we're very fortunate
that we have a lot of the people
associated with the with the program
here to actually give you real answers
to questions you might have um again for
the record my name is Mike Edgar and I
represent Hampton in the New Hampshire
house um I'm also a member of the uh oil
fund dispersement board okay uh thank
you madam chair and committee members
for allowing me to introduce HB 658 to
you
today the bill authorizes raising the
cap on certain reimbursements from the
oil discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
it reauthorizes the collection of oil
import Fe license fees and adjusts the
fee
amounts uh the present authorization
that provides a funding will expire
expire on July 1st of this year um so
this bill reauthorizes it through July
1st of
2035 okay uh the basis for this action
is a chapter uh uh
146a um and I'll read some of this and
I'll leave the rest of it for you to to
read yourself but the uh decoration of
purpose in in in
the RSA I just uh mentioned is the
purpose of this chapter is is to cope
with the problem of pollution from the
spillage or or discharge of oil
recognizing the damage resulting to
vegetation marine animal and bird life
uh from such pollution uh is the intent
of this chapter provide procedures that
will expediate expedite the cleanup of
oil spillage mitigate the adverse
effects of oil discharges
encourage preventive measures and
provide financial assistance to victims
of such discharges and to encourage
private organizations to assist in these
efforts okay um uh the gut of this when
you look at the bill um is to uh is to
change the amount that be re bured uh uh
in a couple different ways the owners of
on premises use facilities who have
demonstrated Financial need May apply
for reimbursement of costs to meet local
Department operating standards in
amounts not to exceed a total of now be
$4,000 and apply for reimbursement of
underground storage tank abandonment or
removal costs in amount not to exceed a
total of
45,000 okay any person who Imports or
causes to be imported oil into into the
state except those using oil pipelines
railroads and highways to transport oil
products between states other than the
Hampshire or for international transport
of oil products shall be licensed by the
department of safety under this
chapter the annual fees will increase as
is
shown um to meet the needs that we have
now it's been a long time since they've
been
increased and the fees that are outlined
here will be uh paid monthly by such
persons to the Department of
Safety the oil fund dispersed m board
requests this bill requested this bill
and supports its passage please consider
voting OTP on HB 658 for for raising the
cap on certain reimbursements from oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
reauthorizes the collection of oil
import license fees and adjust those
amounts and U that concludes what I was
saying if anybody has any questions that
they want to ask me if I can answer them
I will otherwise I'll defer to uh uh the
great people we have here to actually
give you the the answers on
this okay and representative jman do you
need to return to your seat you may
sure uh representative kto has a
question for you uh thank you madam
chair and thank you representative um
one of the things you mentioned in your
testimony uh that you were saying was
that there was going to be
increases um it looks like there's going
to be increases in the amount of
reimbursement but an overall
decrease in the um amounts charged per
gallon is that correct there there was a
quite a study done um that we had to we
brought people in for that and some
increase some
decrease follow follow with the purpose
of having it you know with the amounts
that are used of those particular items
uh so that we do actually collect more
money total at the end okay um
so this would only be so I'm looking at
this and I'm looking okay onroad and
off-road diesel uh is going to decrease
by 0.0001 cents per gallon um but then
there was a line here that says let me
just uh so you know what line I'm
talking
about
was uh there'll be an increase per fuel
oil diesel products and used oil for on
premise heating can you tell me what
that that is please because that is an
increase and when I see Home Heating I
get a little
concerned okay I'm trying to figure out
uh just which line you uh it is the one
that is going from
01375 to
02715 line oh so line 19 okay that that
in yeah there's an there is an increase
there yeah
yeah follow up thank you um but what I I
asked what are those exact
products if you could explain those
please I'll tell you what I think it is
and then uh we can ask the people that
really know what it is uh in a minute
I'm afraid I already told you uh
probably more than I know but I can tell
you some more okay thank you I'll I'll
wait for f the T we'll wait then for
representative Bixby you had a question
um mine was kind of on the same line as
representative comp was I'm just a
little bit I wanted a little
clarification of of the changes in the
fees uh sounds like that you are not may
not be the best person to it would be
correct to to say to uh ask that
question of someone following you uh yes
it definitely would be and I I believe I
kind of indicated that to begin with but
okay and I just like to thank you for
bringing forward this bill because it's
a very use useful and important program
oh you're welcome
any other questions representative uh
I'm sorry grber like what yes uh thank
you uh Madam chair uh thank you for
testifying I had I looked at the um the
estimated roughly $17 million of income
from these fees um and the cost uh for
providing oil tank uh removal and for
those who can't afford it and that adds
up to roughly $1 or2 million so uh where
do the rest of revenues in end up going
into
State there there is a um a formula it's
used for that certain amount is
collected and it's it it's deposited in
one place and then after that it's used
so um is it all used on on remediation
work or is it used for
other some goes into the I believe uh
and that can be asked in a minute into
the the general fund but the stuff there
is a good portion of it is used to
actually do the
remediation uh of of spills and things
and also there's the part in here where
if somebody's having an oil tank that's
getting ready to go bad where you can
actually replace it before it goes bad
which is you know a pretty good
idea thank you okay any other questions
thank you so much for coming and
introducing this bill um B Bishop from
NHD New Hampshire Department of
good afternoon Madam chair and committee
members my name is Bob Bishop I am the
administrator of the oil remediation and
compliance Bureau at New Hampshire Dees
seated with me is Jennifer Marts she is
the supervisor of our fund management
section the oil fund dispersement Board
of which representative Edgar is a
member is administratively attached in
statute to the Department of
Environmental Services it's part of that
administrative attachment we have a fund
management section Jennifer is the
supervisor of that section that oversees
the use of the funds on behalf of the
board so the oil fund dispersement board
decides how these funds are to be used
and then Jennifer implements that
portion of the
program this bill impacts the oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund
representative Edgar just mentioned it
also has some impact on the oil
Pollution Control fund which is a
separate fund that is managed by the
Department of Environmental Services so
as he mentioned that the bill makes four
changes and those changes are in both
146d and that is the the statute that
governs the oil discharge and disposable
cleanup fund and the oil fund board
and in 146a which the oil spill
Pollution Control
Act those changes as you mentioned one
is to change the date of due date of an
annual report the other is to raise that
cap on reimbursement for substandard
tanks for lowincome
homeowners the third extends the the
collection of the fees for the oil
discharge and Disposal cleanup fund for
an additional 10 years and includes a
10year sunset of the collection of those
fees and the fourth readjusts the fees
which I understand there were some
questions on a few moments
ago and so the the odd fund we call it
the oil discharge and Disposal cleanup
fund primarily what it does is it
reimburses for corrective action cleanup
costs for spills from tank storage
facilities where there is no insurance
to pay for that cleanup so it's
basically an excess insurance and that's
where the primary expenditure of that
money goes to probably around the order
of $1 million a year is spent on cleanup
of oil
spills a million dollars a year being
spent on the program the safe tank
program we call it where that replaces
those home heating oil
tanks also the fund satisfies financial
responsibility requirements that owners
of underground storage tank systems have
both federally and in State
Statute that uh financial responsibility
requirement is basically insurance that
they have to have in order to have a gas
station or underground storage tank and
when this fund was initially set up
insurance for that was pretty difficult
to obtain and that was recognized in in
the statement by the general court in
the purpose uh for the fund and so it's
still also a a financial responsibility
mechanism the oil Pollution Control fund
the other one that I mentioned out of
146a that is for the Department of
Environmental Services spill response
and prevention programs so that fund
pays for a 24hour a day 7day per week
spill response program that is run at
the Department of Environmental Services
also for vention program regulation of
those underground storage tanks such as
at gas
stations The Spill response program
responds to about 300 petroleum spills a
year and that varies from year to year
and the the large portion of those are
not what would be eligible under this
odd fund the largest portion are motor
vehicle accidents uh but we do respond
to approximately 100 home heating oil
releases year again that fluctuates from
year to year and we also respond to
releases from other uh sources and other
tank systems although those releases are
are less than 10 every year that we see
from those types of tank
systems so I'd open it up to to
questions I know there were a few
already that Jennifer and I can probably
answer for okay I I'll I'll start off
with the questions and then we'll go
around
so I'm I'm interested to know I mean you
01546 how are those numbers developed I
mean why isn't it just uh you know two
cents a gallon or whatever sure and and
this comes on the recommendation of the
oil fund dispersement board they put
this together and this is based on an
Actuarial review that they had performed
of the fund a company called Taylor and
Moulder performed an Actuarial review
for the board and what they were looking
at for these different categories of
petroleum that's imported is the cost in
those types of categories that we have
corrective action cleanup and they
sought to as balance as best as possible
for the import fees on gas and Diesel to
pay for gas and Diesel releases the
import fees for fuel oil to pay for
those hea oil releases the import fees
for motor oil to pay for the motor oil
releases and so they were looking to
balance as best as possible and the
Actuarial firm came up with these
numbers that go out to quite a few
digits and the board decided to leave it
as such as opposed to trunk creating it
to a more round number that could be
easier to use that was a board
decision okay represent Bixby yes thank
you for taking my question so uh sort of
following up on that uh I noticed that
some of these numbers have some of these
fee numbers have gone down some of them
have gone up is that um a result of a
change in the uh calculated risk
multiplied by the amount of uh of that
type of uh oil that is being uh brought
into the state the answer is yes that
that is what that change is is
predicated upon uh but it it really gets
into the
existing projects that we have so we
have about 1,200 existing petroleum
contaminated sites that we're
administering to the cost of those over
the next 10e period and any new releases
that may occur over that period as well
and then looking and that's where that
part of the risk comes in looking at at
the
individual petroleum types that are
feed follow up follow up yep so
um do these have these fees been
calculated essentially with a goal of uh
generating a balance in the fund that is
going to that is very well matched
towards the ex known and expected
costs the the the idea would be for it
to match exactly to that but it's so
hard hard to predict you know out 10
years in the future but yes that is if
you could match something 12 10 years
out in the
future you'd have a good career in a lot
of other
Industries so that is that is the
purpose okay thank
you uh representative K thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here um
I'm just going to follow up on one of
the questions that I asked um
specifically
online 19 um in 20 um we're doing a
decrease on on-road and off-road
gasoline and diesel fuel but we're doing
an increase per gallon of fuel oil
diesel products and used oil for on
premise heating can you tell me what the
fuel oil diesel products and used oil
for onome what that is yes please I'm
just yes and so that category
represents fuel that's used for heating
purposes so all of those items so in
includes home heating oil the board
during their October meeting and when
they decided what they would land on
here um recommended that the fee from
the current fee on that be essentially
doubled the Actuarial review landed on a
much higher amount because we do have
quite a bit as I mentioned we do about a
100 home eating oil releases our spill
response team goes to to every year and
so that is a category that continues to
have a number of
releases and that gets more to fuel oil
paying for the releases that come from
fuel oil tanks as opposed to the gas and
Diesel paying for it the gas and Diesel
is the largest on volume that gets
imported to the state so when you look
at these numbers it's really that number
times the gallons that give you what the
the financial impact is and so that
number um really has to go with that
gallon to really make sense follow up
thank you madam chair and thank you for
that exp that explanation
um so my other question to you is is
this is just on
imported
fuel um as opposed to I mean when we say
imported do we mean what exactly do we
mean because it looks like um
can you just explain that to me please
because it was pretty sure so that
that's petroleum that is coming into the
state for primarily for use with or
storage within the state and so any that
comes into the state it's going to be
used here that's what these apply to oil
that's passing through the state this
doesn't apply but it's oil imported into
New Hampshire the other okay one more
followup I need two but okay um H the so
technically all fuel I I'm making an
assumption here and correct me if I'm
wrong is imported into the state of New
Hampshire would that be correct that is
correct although some fuel passes
through that's why I was making that
distinction yes right so would these
costs especially on the home heating
fuel be passed on to the
consumer uh I'm I'm not part of the
industry so I'm not sure how they manage
that U but an assumption would yes but
I'm not part of that okay um we had
representative King and then down to
Scully thank you madam chair thank you
for being here
today um I have a very slight background
in computer programming and in computer
programming um when you have just hard
numbers that are in the code that's
that's called a magic number and one of
the things that just makes me scratch my
head a little bit is that all of these
numbers in here the dollar amounts um
you know I can imagine that over time
with inflation at say 10 or
15% and you guys are projecting out
several years I'm just wondering did you
guys put you know bake into the formula
a 10 or 15% inflation rate and if not um
you know I think one of the problems I
have with magic numbers is the fact that
they so frequently need to be changed
and to me I
I don't want future legislators to have
to come in every year or two and like go
over this whole process again just to
change numbers it seems like a better
way now I don't know but it seems like a
better way would just be like a formula
that were put into the code so that you
know you guys could do what you need to
do and that formula basically is static
and it just stays the same for years and
years so that you guys aren't having to
come back here every few years to like
change numbers again am I missing
something I'm I'm not sure I I will
address that the Actuarial review
included a 2% adjustment for inflation
right year-over-year
um regarding whether this could be done
with
a with a formula placed into the statute
it's not something we've considered it
wasn't something that we had to go on
historically what we have had is is a
10-year sunset
in order to force us to look at what
these fees will be and of course the
board can reassess what their fees are
and look for future legislation before
that 10year time period is up that
hasn't happened in the last 10 years so
we go back to 2015 when the last change
was
made follow up yet okay so since it it's
been 10 years did you find that there
was any shortfall like because you guys
originally had these numbers and
inflation I think has been a lot higher
than 2% annually in the last 10 years
I'm just wondering did you guys find out
that your projections were way under
budget or did it come out just right so
using the the the fees have been
adjusted here and it and it is I did
hear earlier there was a question
overall it's an 8% increase that it
represents I know it's hard to see that
with these because there's all these
different fees uh for different types of
petroleum
um so there is an 8% overall increase
and that was why the board hired the
Actuarial firm to review what our
liabilities versus our income might be
over the next 10e time frame and they
did find with current fees that we would
end up with a negative balance I think
it was by year seven
or8 by
2034 we would not have a fun
existing for what was the perceived
liability still
existing and so this 8% increase enables
the fund
to essentially have a a year or a half a
year of liabilities covered when it
sunsets okay representative wheeler
thank you madam chair uh this should be
a much simpler question than the others
um on line four you changed the uh date
of the report to the governor and
Council the Speaker of the House Etc to
from October 1 to March one uh can you
just elaborate on that a little B more
sure October 1st was a difficulty both
for the administrative faction of the of
the board so the the agency to get all
of the previous years's fiscal fiscal
year ending numbers together and put
together in package for the board for
the annual report and then also to have
a board meeting where they could review
that have a discussion on it and approve
that that annual report gets moved
forward so is it a combination of of how
close that was to the end of the fiscal
year and basically our accounting unit
having to put together end of year and
beginning of your numbers in time for a
board meeting and so that board meeting
would have had to in August would have
been pushing that to get that to
governor and councel by October
1st representative
Bixby am I correct in recalling that uh
we had an amendment put on to some other
bill in the last uh two or three years
to increase the reimbursement for uh
tank upgrades because what was had been
the case wasn't the case yes that is
correct uh believe it was in
2022 that uh that came uh before the
legislature and that was to increase the
safe tank so that the reimbursement for
financial qualified homeowners to
receive uh a new heating oil tank when
there's a substandard follow follow up
yep and then seem that that seem that
seems to suggest that if the numbers
don't work out uh if if the 10-year
projection doesn't work out there's a
way to deal with it is that correct the
the board could always request
additional legislation to deal with that
yes thank you okay and U my apologies
representative Scully I should have
gotten you in the queue earlier but go
ahead and ask a question thank thank you
madam chair no no problem um the
legislation on lines 19 um 22 and 23
says the department shall of safety
shall deposit into the um 125 ,000 in
fees paid to the general fund is that a
requirement of
law
so that has been within the statute for
quite a quite a few years and I'm I'm
not
sure exactly why that's required perhaps
there is an administrative statute that
requires some amount to go into the
general fund but uh we we left that the
same as it is in the current
statute and the Department of Safety is
is who collects these
fees and then they move them over into
the the the two different funds that we
were talking about all right just just
want quick follow up S all right
so which uh statute does that requires
that is that uh one you're amending
here so that was put in the original La
statute that yes so the statute that's
being amended here is where that
$125,000 in
fees was original
listed all right thank
you first goes so um do you have
administrative Personnel in the
department that uh are overseeing this
that are not paid by the um paid by the
direct directly from the
fund oh all of our administrative
Personnel that uh work on behalf of the
board are paid from the fund okay so
would that include you
that and I I am paid out of the oil
Pollution Control fund so that's okay
one of the two right and and Jennifer's
paid out of the other one because I was
thinking there might be some general
funded position that would be covered by
that but I'm not that's that's look
looking less clear so thank
you okay and I have a question um if
this bill were not to pass what would
happen if this bill was not to pass then
the the current fees would be sunset the
fees for the oil Pollution Control fund
would continue at the rate that they are
at and so that would fund that spill
response side of things and then there
wouldn't be money for the the 12200 or
so sites that we currently have that are
contaminated that are going through some
form of corrective action or groundwater
monitoring um and so that that that
money wouldn't exist and there also
would not be
financial responsibility mechanism for
underground storage tank systems they
would have to go out and seek their own
mechanism in order to continue to
operate those systems okay and just as a
followup how much does it cost for all
the um remediation work and that you
said that you wouldn't have money to do
that what what does that cost and ually
so annually um we get we have
appropriated by the legislature 122.5
million to use for that reimbursement of
those corrective actions and that also
includes that safe tank program the tank
replacement so about 11.5 million goes
right to actual
remediation work or groundwater
monitoring work or work to uh to
investigate um where in the subsurface
that petroleum might be and what it may
impact and so that wouldn't wouldn't
happen necessarily without this funding
okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much appreciate your
time I have t the last pink card is Tom
froley chair of the oil fund
good
afternoon Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Tom froley I live
in Lime New Hampshire I'm chairman of
the oil fund dispersement board um I've
been chair for the last three years and
I've been on the board for the last 20
plus years so uh and I'm here
representing also uh industry you could
say because we I own a p distribution
company that supplies independent
gasoline uh owners uh in throughout the
New England states including New
Hampshire Vermont Massachusetts so I I'm
on both sides of this from the
perspective of I understand what benefit
this program is created for individual
owners and how individual communities
have been benefactors of this fund and
how it's functioned and the uh Madam
chair you you brought up a really great
question that said what happens if this
fund doesn't exist anymore and the
reason it was created is private
insurance just didn't exist and what
ended up happening it wasn't major oil
companies that were the ones who were
responsible for cleaning up individual
small community gas station issues that
arose it was the individual owners so
these individual small community owners
and we all have them there small country
stores in our site in our communities
and 70 or 80% of all these stations are
privately held small individual U owners
and so they would be responsible for
paying the extreme cost associated with
potentially cleaning up and creation of
the fund is uh the previous speakers
said also came with some caveats that
said you got to be in compliance so you
got to follow the rules you got to be
educated you got to make sure that
you're following these rules in order to
be eligible for the fund so it worked
and it's had it's worked very well for
the last 20 plus years so I'm I'm here
to just answer questions my testimony as
chairman was uploaded earlier I'm not
going to bore you with reading through
it so if uh anyone has any questions I'd
be glad to answer representative wheeler
thank you madam chair just an
informational
question where would one be able to
research more about your board is are
the minutes available online things like
that yes they're available online it's
the oil fund dispersement board and we
meet uh uh probably every other month or
once a quarter I think at this
point and I have a question as to who
determines who is a member of that board
yeah the board is a is a collection of
Representative Senators uh members from
uh the Department of Environmental
Services a couple of who you met here
and also members of Industry so we have
members representing the heating oil
industry myself came on as a
representative of the refiners and uh
oil distributors who are the folks who
pay all the import fees you know for all
that oil and gasoline that gets imported
into the state so I hope I think that
answers the question so we've got a
collection of uh subject matter experts
from Private Industry and also from the
Department of Environmental Services and
also the Senate and representatives okay
and how uh just to uh Echo a question
previously by representative ktoa um how
does an increase in these fees affect
the consumer what is that in the end
well you got to talk a little bit about
what's happening in our world right now
we're seeing a significant reduction in
the amount of heating oil being used out
there and we're also seeing a reduction
in the amount of gasoline and diesel
fuel that's being used out there and
that's as a result of of you know fuel
economy the Advent of alternative
Vehicles EVS uh heating oil equipment
that's much more efficient so the net
effect is the average consumers
purchasing less hydrocarbons so as a
result our fees and our actual study
shows it based on you know Trends and
projections that we're going to see less
gallons okay coming in at as the basis
for how this fund functions so that
means we have to come up with mechanisms
to sort of meet that demand as we look
into the future you know and I think it
was talked about where it's kind of a
math somebody talked about being a math
expert and I say you know when you look
at an 8% fee increase especially in you
know home heating oil that's a
significant consideration but when you
look at the fact that they're all using
less gallons the total dollars that
we're actually collecting is comparable
to what the fund has been collecting all
along because we're using so much less
so it's a little bit of a you pay a
little bit more per gallon but you're
using less
gallons okay any other questions from
the
committee seeing none oh well
representative ktoa you got that under
the wire I did thank you madam chair and
thank you for being here and uh
explaining this a little bit further uh
I'm just looking on the fund is there a
place where it lists the um
members um I'm having difficulty and I
didn't know if it was somewhere uh if
that's right on the website I I believe
it is on the website but I sure couldn't
tell you where it is thank
you
okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you for your time and educating us on
this uh on this fund and uh the
processes behind it we appreciate your
time thank you very much thank
you okay okay uh blue sheet for this
particular Bill HB
658 and I am going to oh yeah on the
online portal we had 12 people in
support zero
opposition on our blue
have three people in
support zero oper opposition I'm going
to close the hearing
658 and my apologies to everyone who has
been waiting very
patiently um that we are
behind uh we were supposed to begin our
hearing for hb77 at 2 o'clock it is now
2:45 so I hope we can make up some time
on
this I am going to open the hearing for
hb77
and uh let's see who is
the
yes rep representative Penza is uh
presenting another bill in another
committee at the moment okay and she's
the prime sponsor okay I'm happy to
introduce the bill for the purposes
of okay beginning discussion okay and
then if you'll clarify the rule for me
am I allowed to return to the committee
if I just introd yes you may okay as far
as I understand you may uh if you are
introducing a bill on behalf of someone
else you may come back to your chair and
um and be you know question
testifiers and if uh representative
patens a returns um we can give her a
chance also to talk okay thank you
yeah so we'll wait a moment have
representative ger present the bill to
us
what is
that
just I'm sorry representative ger hold
on one moment sure okay are we all set
here okay uh representative German
thank you welcome thank you madam chair
for the record my name is Nick gerana I
represent chesher 15 which is Hinsdale
Chester Field Keen Wards one and three
through five Siri Walpole and westerland
uh and so I'll just very quickly
introduce uh the bill I would point out
to the committee something oh and
representative Patza is here is
here would we would love you to
all
right thank you madam chair um for the
record my name is representative Kelly
Penza straford District
19 Rochester Wards 1 two 3 four and six
um sorry I had to present other bills
and I filed too many bills this year
been there done that we all know thank
you so
much so I'm not sure what did you say
no okay all
right
um okay so the reason why this bill came
forward is um really due to being part
of this rules process for um you know in
a sense over a year
and and then of course I was on the
subcommittee here for rules as well and
so um we lived and breed these rules
during that whole time and um and so I
was able to see things firsthand and so
that's the also the reason why we have
so many different co-sponsors on this as
well and then what happened um through
Jael car and when they first denied the
rules and then they realized that or
they felt that they realized that it was
um that they were making more of a
policy decision
um and that that's the legislature's
role um we decided to put these into
policy
so basically right now we have from one
criteria alone the weakest rules in the
world they're produced under a statute
that literally says just go ahead and
write the rules this bill exactly um is
what we need it's the guard rails really
so it improves a set of um improves a
set of
rules that basically Dees doesn't even
have to work on for these little items
that I've put in here um because the
legislature did all the work um to get
to where we are today through hundreds
of hours of testimony experts research
talking to other states all of that so
in the bill at the end of the bill um
it's one of the most important parts of
the bill it it's from lines on page
three from 31 to 36 and it's basically
changing an introductory paragraph and
it says the commissioner have shall have
the responsibility and authority to
adopt rules under RSA 541a that are
necessary to protect the public health
and the environment with an ample margin
of safety relative to this chapter so
those 10 words basically that
modification makes it clear that our
their job really is to protect the the
environment not to just write the
rules so I just want everybody to
remember because I wasn't here at that
point um in 22 uh 2022 the house and the
Senate passed site specific setb rules
um it was it was the bill was 1454 I
think it was representative um Matt
Simon um put it forward but it was
vetoed by the governor and then we
almost got it overwritten we were able
to get it overwritten in one chamber so
but Dees already knew in a sense what
what the legislator's intent was um and
this completely these new rules have
completely missed the Mark I would say
tenfold um Dees was also told a very
long time ago that Solid Waste
permitting should be sight specific and
moreover it's where the legislative
intent is the bills that have been filed
over the last five to six years clearly
state what the legislature has been
trying to do um so the March 2024 Draft
rules um they were already the weakest
in the world it allowed pollution to
move at three feet per day whereas Most
states and countries restricted to a
couple of feet per year but then long
after public comments ended de adds Dees
added actually one piece of this um it
was a Gravely dangerous sentence to the
rules which eliminates even that weakest
World weakest in the in the world test
and allows a landfill to be built
anywhere in the state as long as there's
24 in of imported dirt under it that
sentence explicitly allows the dirt to
transmit pollution at 3 Ines per day
which of course is 8 days to go through
24 Ines of
soil so
like I said the bill already has 14
co-sponsors seven from each party
including three from the
Senate we all agree with um we all
agreed with jel Carr that the rules are
contrary to public interest and contrary
to statute so this bill simply picks up
the ball and changes the rules and
changes the statute but in a small and
fundamental
way um I wanted to I know it's been
talked about a lot when we talk about
solid waste the governor has has
strongly signaled her opposition to the
Dalton project you know and that
situation um is is basically you know
more Grim now for that project than it
was even a month ago but the rules and
this is the most important thing it's
not about one project right now the
rules will allow a landfill to be put
pretty much
anywhere so if the rules are not
Rewritten Rewritten some company could
come in could come to nashwa could come
to Keane
conquered wherever and find another
terrible track of land and claim that
the rules entitled them to build
there
so basically um the Rewritten rules
absolutely do not make it impossible or
even hard to site a landfill in a decent
location one thing we know for sure is
that the current rules are the most
permissive in the world and do not
exempt virtually any tract it should be
hard to cite a landfill and you may hear
testimony um later this afternoon from
people who want it to be so easy so that
no thought needs to be put into the
location those people are gambling with
every resident in this state and one
that wrote opposing testimony that we
all received is a paid contractor for
the industry that is working on the only
permit that is in
de's um office at this
point I want to um make it clear that
I've had some conversations with the
industry about my bill and there has to
be some
changes um there's a couple places in
here
where I was I'd say that I got a little
aggressive and those are up for some
changes um one was a at the 10 mile
radius um in here um and another was the
Ford Act is already law so um that's not
really an issue it doesn't necessarily
have to be in the bill but we wanted it
in listed in the rules since it's
already federal law in regards with
permitting around um of course airports
and such um and then of course um with
violations that can be changed as well
um to maybe say repeated violations you
know Bad actors repeat offenders um but
I also do want to say that already um an
automatic deny of a landfill that is um
of a permit application is if the um if
the person putting the permit the
company um has broken the law in the
sense of where they're being sued
currently so if there's an active
lawsuit you're not allowed to put it a
permit so we're already protected by
that so because of that reason it makes
me feel better in regards with the
violation pieces that I have here in
this bill and on that note I think I've
covered
everything
okay um you have a pink slip that you
filled out for your testimony no but
I'll I'll do and I want to thank you for
your work on this very important Bill
thank you um I don't know any other
questions representative Bixby yeah I uh
I think this might be covered under what
you you one of the things you mentioned
needs to be um reworked a little bit but
um on page
three uh line
18 uh no permit for the operation of
solid Wasteland fill shall be issued in
New Hampshire for any applicant who has
been found in violation of any federal
state or local environmental laws
regulations or permit conditions
anywhere in the United States uh and
uh so that is all going to be reworked
that's that so so you're going to rework
that so that if it's a permit if it's if
if it's a violation that has been
brought to the attention of the landfill
operator and they are working on
remediating it that that is not a
correct problem exactly okay thank
you questions representative rer whoops
thank you for what it seems like a very
important uh bill um there's a I think
this might just been an oversight but in
um the distance for the setback
initially you referred to portable water
supply PR Rivers lake or Coastal water
but later I guess that's on um line 24
page 1 we don't have portable water qual
Aqua for there so you may want to uh
check make sure we're consistent with
where you're measuring from so on on
line 24 page one a poble water aquafer
is not listed what what page is that
page page one line 24 page one line
24 okay yeah so just make certain that
we know we're measuring from the same
points on all Y and that's that also you
have that on page uh page two uh
line8 same thing we insert the uh
potable water aquifer if that's
intentional location perfect thank you
otherwise thank you very much I
appreciate it oh I'd also like to bring
up um it was an oversight by um OS and
mistake so I've already put in an an
amendment to it's literally one word so
on page three
line8 and this is this basically this um
hydraulic conductivity this is the this
is the meat of this bill this is one of
this is the most important thing what I
was talking about which makes us the
weakest in the world um it's supposed to
say no amount of imported soil can
overcome not come so there was a can
come such deficiency so um I didn't send
it to her wrong so it was it wasn't mine
so um OS doesn't usually do copy and
paste they they're very good about
retyping so that's where but that's
already been fixed not including the
on okay um any other questions from the
committee I oh uh represent wheeler
thank you madam chair I'm in The
Boondock so we all try
to my
hand yes exactly a Wheeler
flat thank you madam
chair representative Potenza would you
believe and I know that you brought this
up in your testimony a little bit but uh
I had spoken to somebody who was on Jael
car who voted against those rules
because they
had spoken to somebody from the
Environmental Protection Agency who told
them that these rules were essentially a
joke would you believe that that the EPA
views our environmental rules as a
joke I would believe that um that is why
we are that's why we have other states
that are basically Banning landfills
because they're bringing in you know 50%
of their waste into New Hampshire so
this is the kind of stuff that we have
to look at um landfills are they're a
necessity I get it but they should be
the last thing that were looked at um
and we're not looking at any other
things I I forget when I first started
with the committee there was a wonderful
recycling presentation and I think New
Hampshire was like in the bottom barrel
of that like we're like the worst in the
49th ranking of um in regards with
recycling in in doing all of that it's
taken us a long time to get where we are
right now but a lot of people are awake
they're
um they're really looking at this the
real New Hampshire Advantage is to have
clean drinking water and wonderful clean
spaces we have nothing if we don't have
that representative ger thank you madam
chair thank you representative so could
you explain a little bit
more what you mean when you refer to a
site
specific criteria that obviously has
been a phrase we use a lot it's kind of
a bone of contention but if you could
speak to how this bill is intended to
Pro provide site specific
criteria um I turned off my mic yes
so one specifically if you're talking
about um you know on page three lines 4
through n that right there is very sight
specific there's a lot of other things
in here that talk about um you know
certain setbacks and and stuff like that
but um you know the setback from any
paral River Lake water shell M it's all
about distance of travel so it's not
giving a number so representative Simon
and I used to talk about this all the
time you know we can't just pick some
arbitrary number because of course soil
and and and um and basically you know if
we're not digging down with the Bedrock
and all of that kind of stuff is
different wherever you go I'll never
forget in in when they dug the well
where in our first house um in New
Hampshire that I owned and
conquered you know the neighbor didn't
have a good water flow but we did and we
were literally like right next to each
other so all of the stuff in here is all
based upon time of travel in basically
looking at what that site is you know
what kind of soil it is is it in a
gravel pit is it in a sand pit does it
have Clay all of that kind of stuff is
taken into all of these different
criteria that are put in here so
everything's looked at individually we
don't just say oh 500 set 500 foot
setback that's it that's good enough no
you got to look at everything around it
so follow up thank you and also as I
look at it page one uh line 29 starting
there that's s 17 section one and isn't
this also where the the work of the
hydrologist comes in to perform a
comprehensive evaluation of the specific
site to decide what that fiveyear
setback distance means in terms of space
yes very important 16 through 22 yes
very very
important thank
you uh representative Howard thank you
madam chair um I I remember in last
session I guess my question is is this
meant to displace the rules that that
were put in place in between the time in
the last session when we tried to be um
almost as you know as prescriptive as
rules would be and they there was sort
of a promise made to us that um we
didn't need to legislate it because the
rules were going to be comprehensive and
and updated and all of that and and this
seems like another attempt to help them
you know
uh make law make rules that are that are
that are sight specific and and advanced
into the science of today rather than um
what we what we found in the old rules
before we did it in last session and I'm
just wondering are we going to get the
same push back about rules versus
time well I'm hoping not because
um I think as we learn from from Jael
car that we're supposed to be the policy
drivers and this is really driving that
there's gaps there's a lot of great
things in the new rules but the most
critical things are are missing and and
missing by a mile and this puts them in
and I mean the rules are there're you
know it's a very very long document so
it's it's really an 800 rule but there's
multiple things that you know it's they
call it one rule but all these different
things that are in it so this changes
those things which is really important
but the during the whole process the
process was completely broken and um
from the beginning the waste management
Council had no representation of from
for the public or public health there's
you know and basically you had a one
person on there that was helping write
the permit for the only permit that Dees
has that was you know in that room and
saying oh that they're not weak enough
four times the rules changed four times
they were weakened that's a ton and that
wasn't from the public testimony that
was going on there were a lot of private
meetings that were happening that were
that industry is pushing back on Dees to
make them weaker we know that for fact
we have the 91a documents so we just we
got to be the legislature needs to be in
the driver's seat on this there's been
boatloads of expert testimony I I've
been I mean from talking to people in
Maine in Pennsylvania and then we have
wonderful people here that have lived
and breed this that I can't even imagine
the amount of time that they spent on
all of these things unpaid and and
public testimony every bit of the public
testimony that has ever come in through
um Dees was all against it every single
thing the documents that we put together
representative of gerana could speak to
this as well pose me a question um we we
gave this whole long document and said
why why why why can't you do this this
and this and not one of those things
ever got put into the rules so uh we had
a a wonderful hydrogeologist that came
and presented it to us and gave us this
chart if this committee wants all of the
data I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna bury you
with the book of it I will I mean it's
hard you don't know what you don't know
but when you live and breathe this oh my
gosh it's glaring and we've got to make
the changes and the time is
now okay any other
questions I only have one question in so
far as um you know i' I've heard talk
about the one by 10 to the minus5 cm per
is that
threshold that stringent threshold
necessary based on the fact that we
require in New Hampshire two liners for
a landfill where other states do not
require two
liners good question um I'm not familiar
with um liner requirements around other
other stat stes I do believe that that
has someone has gone and looked at that
um I know that the main landfill I
believe that they require two liners we
just looked into that one they're a
public private landfill um
so it's
still liners fail there's nothing that
can stop it they're going to leak
eventually and if there's two great it
won't leak as soon as we know from
documents that we have
um from supplied by Dees there was a
puncture in the NCS ncees landfill in
Bethlehem uh I think about 10 years ago
that's the reason why probably why
that's leaking and you know there's
really not been a lot of anything done
about that so we've got issues here
people make mistakes it's it's going to
happen so you have to make sure that
wherever you're putting it and it's not
stringent I will give you if you don't
have that document it was a document
that we received um on the rule
subcommittee representative ger remember
all the other states in their numbers we
are still if we're at 10 to
the5 um we are
still fairly weaker than I don't know I
would say about 90% of the other states
like you've got South Carolina and
others they're 10 to the7 10 to the6 so
um if there was wiggle room in there um
especially since I've talked with um
another landfill operator that is you
know possibly looking to expand if that
number that 10 to theg5 was going to
hurt them for their
expansion um there's there's room to to
talk about that and bringing it down to
the neg four but to the neg -3 and then
basically round it up is is
insanity and and and my other question
is
um with regard
to
time or this you know to the neg
five
how what percentage of land within the
within New Hampshire would be
um
either o an okay place to put a landfill
versus not an okay place to put in a
landfill do do you have any kind of
percentage of you know would we be able
to build a landfill based on these
numbers we would and I don't have that
at the top of my um fingertips right now
but there was testimony that we got in
that showed I don't know if you remember
this that showed there was a map and
that showed other areas where um you
could side a landfill in the state so
and we would only want like I said
before in testimony on multiple bills
you know we could maybe only have to
have one more one more landfill in the
next 100 years and that's a good thing
so there is there is
space all right uh representative Bixby
and then ger would you believe that the
approximate indication of that map of of
soils that are appropriate for landfill
was about 83% of the land area of the
state
no I didn't know that but thank you I
I'm not going to it's been a couple
years so if if that's not absolutely the
right number I I won't uh you
know I'm not going to guarantee that
exact number but that that was
approximately what I remember from a
couple years ago representative ger
thank you madam chair pardon me
um try to figure out how to phrase the
question pardon me with the some of the
opponents of of this particular number
which has been around for a while right
have have made the argument that there
wouldn't be enough land available in the
state when they have been asked have
representatives of Industry ever
provided any statistical evidence to
support the claim that they would not be
able to site a landfill in this state
with the requirements no thank you
representative Howard and then did you
um when you talk about this 10 to the
neg5 requirement um if you if you put
that same equation next to a body of
water is that is that you know used to
be 200 feet maybe now it's 500 feet or
something um would you would you still
would would the would you would that
override the the math or the or what
would be more important the water or
would it make it to the water yeah
there's it it all kind of works out so
if you and on page two it discuss it
discusses distance of travel estimate so
would they would all kind of match up so
so um
basically there there is I mean there is
a certain amount that you'd have to be
further away than that and because um it
depends I mean it really depends on what
you're talking about here so if it's
like in a wonderful location with clay
and all that and then it still meets up
with the fiveyear distance time of
travel that it's it's it's basically
they both are complimenting each other
they would be both be the same because
the time of travel from the site with 10
to theg5 is the same as like the 5year
distance so they're both kind of um like
parallel to each other or or
complimentary it's better
word okay any other questions represent
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for being here and
presenting this um just a quick question
for you because you've been talking
about other states and everything would
you say New Hampshire's geography is
actually we had someone that testified
on that the hydrogeologist testified on
that she can speak to that better than I
can we are not um there has been the
arguments that were made that oh New
Hampshire is not like any other state
and that's actually not true and she
spoke to that and I can give you her
testimony better um everybody's
different there are differences but you
know our GE our hydrogeology is very
similar to it's got similar to Maine it
has similar to Vermont so um and there's
some pieces of it that are similar to
Massachusetts Massachusetts has has such
vast amount more um property than we do
and it would be great if they didn't
have a ban in place because they could
do a public private landfill and take
care of their own trash and it'd be
wonderful any other
questions thank you representative Penza
appreciate you introducing this
bill I am calling John Swan from safe
Forest Lake up in
sorry I was reminded after our last um
uh hearing similar hearing that placards
like that were not allowed in the
committee room so well apologize
apologies if I broke any rules no no
rules rules I wasn't aware of so good
afternoon Madam chairman CH and members
of the committee uh my name is John Swan
I live in Dalton New Hampshire I'm the
founder of save Forest Lake and um uh
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to provide my import and
support of House Bill 707 requiring the
Department of Environmental Services to
establish a site specific setback
distance for proposed new
landfills um as a prec precursor to my
testimony and in order to not get sued a
third time by cassella Waste Systems I
need you to understand that all this is
my opinion based on my research and
experience um I would urge the committee
to support House Bill 7
707 and I'm here to uh part of my
testimony was my uh my placard uh
detailing a real world example for the
committee of what a poorly cited
landfill looks like that has gone bad
and that would be the NCS landfill in
Bethlehem um it was it was a in 19 I
have the in the documentation I provided
to the committee I did send via email on
page on page three of my testimony there
is a uh a a hydro report from
1984 I believe regarding the sanco
landfill where the NCS landfill is now
signed Ed um and that site it says in
the first paragraph um Harold Brown um
was the former owner in 1976 the site
was formerly a borrow pit so there's
that and then also um uh there's another
um on page the next page there's a uh
report from
GZA um and second paragraph the site
lies within a portion of a Northerly
draining 350 acre Watershed which is
part of the larger amusic River
Watershed so and then it goes down to
say that the site is located
approximately 400 feet Northeast of the
northeast corner of the site um so
basically that's an example of of why we
need this this bill to pass because we
we could we have an opportunity to pres
prevent the mistakes of the past and um
most of the documentation I did send the
committee um details the ongoing and
widespread um site contamination at the
NCS facility uh in Bethlehem um and I
did this is kind of I'm going a little
off topic here off track but
representative Howard asked the question
um
previously would would it make it the
water and what I've provided to you and
what my my map showed uh site map which
is from uh the July 2024 uh groundwater
um monitoring report provided to Dees um
it already is in Bethlehem reaching the
water I've provided test results my own
testing um from October 20th
2023 June 13
2024 uh subsequent testing two weeks
later of the second seep further down uh
Downstream of the uh at the NCS site on
June 27th then on August 15
2024 um and all four of those tests that
I conducted of the seep runoff which
this is a picture of what it looks like
in case you've not seen the video I did
send video link um to two of my uh um
sampling so you could see the force of
the water that's coming off of that
property into the amusic river and my
lab reports showed consistent levels of
contamination with the further
upgradient um monitoring Wells
particularly the b304 well couplet and
the um actually there's a new well uh B
uh
932 that is closer to the amusic river
part of the SSI investigation uh of the
property and that has also shown these
same um four
at least four posos compounds but I will
say that um part of the placard that I
had was part of a mockup I did using the
July 2024 monitoring um results uh
submitted to Dees showing a 78% increase
in total posos levels from prior testing
with seven Wells showing new firsttime
initial posos detections at that
facility as well as 17 and now I correct
that because there's a new well that was
installed in November that is also in
your packet 18 Wells at that property
with um pooa detections and I don't know
if you're familiar with pooa but that is
one of the two posos compounds that the
EPA just deemed as a hazardous uh
substance in uh
2024 um so this facility has a serious
pfoa problem and I guess really again
I'm not going to read my testimony to
you but I would ask I did have a
question for the committee and perhaps
you can even ask this of the department
but are you okay knowing that an
existing operational landfill is allowed
to continue to operate while its own
groundwater monitoring reports have
consistently shown widespread and
ongoing posos contamination of the
surrounding property including the
Watershed of the amk river as well as
the surface water runoff discharge that
I have tested I provided you with the
lab results I've shown I've provided you
links to the video but are you okay with
that continuing
today so with that I'll
uh take any questions if you have any
thank you Mr Swan any questions seeing
none thank you very much for coming this
afternoon I'd like to call Wayne
Morrison
North Country ABC and you've requested
four
minutes good afternoon good
afternoon thank you for uh hearing my
testimony for the record my name is
Wayne Morrison and I am president of a
Grassroots organization called uh North
Country Alliance For balanc
Change six years ago
um when the GSL project was at its
infancy and we've heard about it that
event changed my
life I and members of my group have
spent the last six years educating
ourselves and trying to understand what
the rules are how they apply
what they
mean and that led to you know I'm a
homeowner I'm not a
hydrogeologist but over the last six
years I've hired a hydrog geologist I've
hired a lawyer I've hired a Wetlands
expert I've invested my time and my
energy to try and defend what I think is
you know the best interest not only of
my own property but my neighbors and
ultimately the people of New Hampshire
I've come to realize that citing a
landfill is probably the single most
important decision in in that project's
life there's a ton of engineering and
there's a lot of complexity in the
engineering part of the landfill and
you'll hear a lot about double liners
and monitoring
Wells but where you put one of these
ultimately
dictates the risk that you're putting
people in New Hampshire under and that
risk is not for a week or a month or a
year year or even the life of the permit
which is say 20 years it's at risk for
the next 100 years because even after
continue the old rules when we started
said
that you could site a landfill within
200 feet of Water's
Edge when I first heard
that just a a nobody dumb person living
on a a beautiful Lake up north I said
that can't
be two-thirds of a football field is not
is not the protection I'm looking for
and not just from my site but
anywhere after a number of iterations
conversations a year of rules being
reviewed feedback being
given that rule today is 500
feet and that's if the river is big
enough I guess if it's a smaller River
it's still 200
ft as Governor aot said when she came
and visited Forest Lake she said this
makes no
sense that comment resonates with me
because I think it makes no
sense 200 feet or 500 feet it's hard to
argue that 500 feet is more than 200
feet but both of those numbers in
reality are
meaningless the reason that we need
sight specific science-based setbacks
are because the geology the hydrogeology
of every site is
different and we don't know if 500 ft is
sufficient and we won't know unless we
test the soil and this whole time of
travel is an interesting concept what we
want is a margin of
error we want enough we want enough time
if there's an accident
and I think dees are good people trying
to do the right thing this is not me
shooting uh bullets at they put a year
into trying to update the rules it's a
lot of hard work and nobody likes your
work when you're done I get all of
that but I think the most important
element of all the rules that we talk
about is the sighting piece and and how
far you you put the landfill facility
away from whether it's my Lake a river
the Atlantic Ocean or a drinking water
supp Supply is critical I think this is
a common sense approach to use science
to determine
that I think the simple concept is
that the more porous the soil the
further back from water you should be
that's not that complicated you don't
have to be a hydrogeologist to
recognize that despite our best efforts
despite double liners and monitoring
Wells and and high engineered
systems at the end of the day
unfortunately happens people make
break I I think at some level what we're
recognize that
risk and that how our lakes and our
Rivers and our water bodies and our
drinking supplies are
irreplaceable they are the engine that's
driving our economic boom in the North
Country they're critical to our
long-term health and our long-term
success when we talk about this sighting
criteria 5 years versus 500 feet 500
feet is an arbitrary number we might
debate forever the mechanics of how you
come up with is it 10 the minus 5 is at
10 Theus
4 but coming up with a distance that
allows us enough time to First detect
intercept and remediate a problem before
it hits the water is what we're talking
about and why wouldn't we a on the side
of caution I think we should continue to
drive for all the best practices in the
design of the
landfill but at the end of the day I
would ask this committee as I would ask
anybody I speak to about this this
subject
we should assume at some point the
landfill is going to
fail and when it does the only thing
protecting us is that sighting criteria
that sets it back far enough to prevent
the problem from becoming
irreversible when leech a hits a hits a
lake there is no
remediation there's no fixing that it's
over I don't know how many more
landfills we're going going to need in
New
Hampshire right now I don't think we
need one at all but if we do down the
road we should be very cautious about
where we put it that is the most
important thing we can
decide and I think what jel car I walked
away disappointed that the rules weren't
to my liking they weren't strong as I
would like them but what resonated with
decision Dees has a lot of great people
they're in The Fray every
day but somewhere along the line the
legislature has to weigh in and say you
know
what it is our view that we need to be
extremely
cautious we need to air on the side of
if there's a failure do we have enough
separation between that site and a water
supply that's all we're
asking this is you can make this
extremely complicated there's a lot of
math there's a lot of science at the end
of the day when I stand on my Dock and I
look across and I say a huge landfill is
going to be within sight within less
than a half a mile from my
Lake I just can't believe that's that's
the best practice that's the best that
New Hampshire can offer its citizens it
makes no sense and as governor governor
aot
it it's an important time for us right
the fact that it makes no sense
coincides with we have ignored this
issue for the better part of the last 20
years the good news is we haven't had a
new
landfill nobody can remember when we had
a new landfill it's all been expansions
it's all been Town dumps that have been
bought and
expanded we need a place to start and
the time to start is
now and I I I think before we get lost
to the minutia of who shot who and how
and and what what are all the individual
how do you do this and how do you do
that there's people that can figure that
out but the policy part the part that
really matters is the legislators
standing up and saying we need to do
better we need to be more protective and
the time to do that is now and I'm here
to say I support this bill there may be
warts and pimples on it maybe there
needs to be some amendments but the
heart of this bill is the right thing
for New Hampshire and now's the right
time to implement it and I I urge you to
work through this and get this
legislation through thank you thank you
any
questions thank you very much Mr
manzelli yeah I hope you're not going to
do and uh I I want to just be cognizant
of the time please thank you thank you
um thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh my name is Amy manzelli
from BCM environmental and land law
where I am a lawyer and I'm here
representing North Country Alliance for
balance change as their Council uh in
strong support of House Bill
707 and I primarily want to talk with
you about how this bill brings a modern
scientific approach to citing
landfills so I'm basically just going to
give you an orientation to the materials
that I've submitted um I did bring one
hard copy this this is just one copy um
I'm sort of uh doing what representative
Penza threaten to do which is providing
all of the voluminous science in support
of
hb77 um and I'm not going to read it
we're just going to hit the highlights
before I do that though I want to
provide further answer to the question
about why do we need a site specific
setback when New Hampshire has a double
liner
requirement so um what happened at ncees
the landfill that's operated in
Bethlehem may may I stop you a minute
because that that actually wasn't my
comment or question um I I questioned
the um
minus5 number with regard to comparison
with other states that don't have a
double liner
requirement so
they're they're set not not setback but
their travel time is a lot more
stringent because they don't have a
double liner requirement that's what I
was um referring to yep no I I
understand and thank you for the
clarification chair um but I did want to
explain the nature of the liner failure
um because that is part of the answer it
doesn't matter how many liners you have
whether it's one or a double or perhaps
more than that um not only do they fail
in and of themselves there's also
operator error and that's what happened
at
ncees so um over 11 years
ago uh cassella the operating the parent
company there was having monitor ing
Wells installed and their contractors
drilled holes right through an overliner
and it took 10 years for anyone to
figure it out and so last year they
reported 10 years worth of a leak and
that is not uncommon in landfill
operation situations so when we're here
talking about the need for a fiveyear
setback that's a real world example why
and there's another component of why we
need a time-based setback um even if
there's a double liner requirement and
that's because most of the leachate
handling operations at a solid waste
facility are completely separate from
the area where there's a liner so the
liner is where uh you know the big hole
is right there's the big hole where you
put the trash that's where the single or
double liner is and then there are other
parts of the facility where uh the leee
tank uh tanker truck is getting filled
up and driving
out there's no liner under that area so
if there's um a leak there there's no
double or single liner protection so I
just wanted to add those
clarifications all right so what we're
endeavoring to do with this very
voluminous package which you all have in
your email is we want to give you you
everything you need to support and
understand what's going on with
hb77 so that you will vote OTP which is
what we are strongly urging you to do um
we know this is the first time this
committee is considering this particular
bill so as I said I'm just going to kind
of give you a walk through here not a
deep dive um everybody else has talked
about the process as to how we got here
but in some you know what we heard from
both the department and jail car is
these are policy changes that the
legislature has to make so here we are
um we talk about the uh North Country
Alliance for balance change team and so
these resources include input from our
hydrogeologist Muriel robinet our civil
engineer honor Bond day um as well as
myself and the ncbac team which is
comprised of their board and
members and as as Mr Morrison said we
have been this for a number of years and
have by virtue of that gotten pretty
well versed in these
issues so there's an exhibit a and what
that does is it Compares what were the
prior rules which uh with what are the
current rules and it breaks it down with
red uh green and yellow um you'll see
that as your first exhibit red is where
the rule got weaker green is where the
rule got stronger yellow is where the
change was essentially neutral and we've
provided some analysis that uh
explains what the nature of the
technical change was and all that
analysis comes from our hydrogeologist
and our civil
engineer the next thing which is the
bulk it's about 350 Pages it's exhibit B
and what that is is study
after study after study of peer reviewed
science that supports that something in
the range of a 10 to the4 or a 10 to
the5 is the modern gold standard for
landfill sighting setback hydraulic
conductivity Mr Morrison said it just as
plain English as you can get you know if
you're going to have le leaking through
sand versus lee8 leaking through clay
clay is obviously better uh that's how a
non-scientist would talk about it but we
are giving you the peer-reviewed science
so you yourselves can become familiar
with
this and then the last thing is the
multi-state survey so we've actually
provided you with the sighting
requirements the New Hampshire law and
then Maine Vermont Massachusetts and
Rhode Island analoges of those sighting
requirements so instead of just sort of
I mean it's important to make the
statement that New Hampshire's laws are
the weakest in the region and Beyond but
I wanted you as the committee to have
those resources right at your fingertips
so if you want to look up any of those
um again being mindful of the time I
don't have anything further to add
except to say North Country Alliance for
balance change wants to be a resource
for this committee should you have any
questions right this second I would be
very eager to answer them and should you
have any requests or any further
resources we would be happy to provide
those thank you okay thank you very very
much for your testimony representative
King then representative wheeler thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
questions how much participation did NC
ABC have in the crafting of this
bill um I actually I personally had none
um and I don't know the answer to that
please hold Tom are you
testifying okay or Wayne could you
answer
and I can reiterate are we would Madam
chair may he join me he may join you but
yep the answer to your question is we
we've had some part some involvement in
the bill um and it's that bill it's it's
it's been in um multiple iterations so
over over time the bill has matured
we've learned more or so there's been
there's been a number of different
people involved in writing the bill and
it's been written primarily by
scientists so we've had Layman's
involvement but it came from the science
Community thank you thank you
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair uh and thank you madam for taking
my question I guess I'm wondering uh do
you and others feel like the common
sense approach that you tried to bring
to the rules process do you feel like
you were listened to respectfully
throughout that process do people uh in
the North Country Alliance for balance
change feel like they were respectfully
listened to and their concerns were
heard when they tried to bring that to
the process um I think those are two
different questions there's certainly
has been a lot of process and there has
been a high amount of decorum and
respect in the process um but
meaningfully heard no I don't think that
we have been meaningfully heard um but I
do think that the
reason uh provided being
that mostly these are policy level
changes for the legislature to make I
reason representative ger thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question so as you know one of the
changes to the rules late in the game
after a lot of after all all of the
hearings in public input was to say that
if a site was below a certain standard
you could bring in 24 up to 24 Ines of
material um so I I'm wondering if you
could comment on that I mean does that
mean that effectively you could site a
landfill anywhere in the state yes it
does I believe that that is a loophole
so big you could drive a Mac Truck
through it thank you okay any other
questions from the
committee thank you very very much for
for um for providing us with a lot of
research and information that you know
we can certainly uh Endeavor to dig
through thank you madam chair in L of
ambian no problem appreciate all of uh
your your testimony and information as
well and if we do have questions we will
be asking them um Dr
no press the button there there you go
that button okay um yes hello I'm
Cynthia Walter and I do have a doctorate
um in in science I um am speaking I'm
I'm from 22 West conquer Street uh NOA
so I um hadn't planed to speak today but
I I didn't know this bill was being
heard at this time I have researched
this issue and I have personal
experience observing I'm studying uh the
science of water pollution especially
above ground and below ground for 35
years in Western Pennsylvania where
hydrology is complicated and there are
numerous leaks from landfills and all
coal mines and other sorts of discharges
that do make their way into into the
ground and then re PE appear in the um
surface water and in people's homes and
in their wellwater so I have seen first
understand how the traveling of water
from one pollution Source through the
ground and back over into people's homes
and into their mouths um um CAU causing
kidney problems and all sorts of other
issues I've seen that happen firsthand
so I've also read the literature on um
landfill maliner leakage and it's it's
fascinating to see that as good as the
newest liners are um um very well
regarded very well published studies of
um stress uh uh simulations that are
done in real real structures um of
modern landfills show failure rates can
occur in as soon as six
years so it happens very quickly um in
just due to small small fragmentary um
flaws or in the in the placement of the
landfill um liners and so forth so the
idea of landfills failing it's
absolutely so for real um and the idea
of people being impacted
unknowingly by water that has seeped
from One Source above ground through the
ground traveled and then appeared
elsewhere below ground not sorry
elsewhere into into well Waters and into
surface waters without those people
knowing that that water was contaminated
is very real the also there's a problem
with the um and I think it's terrific I
mean there's
so many good things that I'm seeing in
this belt for example the importance of
the uh lee8 handling components being
subject to the profile of the perimeter
of the subject area for the hydrology
testing those I I again I can show you
the reports of polluted not not po water
that was problematic being transferred
to treatment whether it's the trucks or
whether it's being holding tanks and
then the the the leakage lines the
holding tanks um um degrade whatever it
is that problem water the leachate
essentially in this case leaks out
escapes on the surface or below the
surface and there was nothing to to know
that it was being being handled so if
you don't have that
space in that time to catch those leaks
and begin to treat them if you don't
have space or time people will suffer
people will be poisoned and the Water
Supplies will be damaged irretrievably
irrevocably because once that water is
in the ground and on the surface and
reappears it's now in the sediment of
the stream it's now in the sediment of
the lake and you cannot clean sediments
of lakes you cannot clean sediments of
rivers it's a permanent part of that
water supply forever so we have to have
this huge margin of error um associated
with the landfill itself and all the
components of the landfill operations
including lee8 handling so I I think
this is terrific the statistical methods
um that are mentioned as as a pro as
used by the EPA again standard gold Bo
talk about gold standards guys you
really hit the mark and hit the mark
here so I I'm just thrilled to see this
bill show up and and know that all that
science is so real and um thank you so
much for listening appreciate it
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming today um I have one more
pink card and I would invite U director
Michael whimet from New Hampshire Dees
to come and
speak on this
Madam chair sorry good afternoon Madam
chair members of the committee uh thanks
for uh inviting me to speak um I uh the
uh the Hampshire Department
environmental services is not taking a
position on this bill um but as I have
done with a number of other bills um we
feel that it's important to identify any
observations or concerns um that we
think would be of interest to the
committee as they as they consider the
bill and that's what I'm what I'm here
to do um and then what I'll have is a a
handful of mixture of policy and
technical issues that in our review of
the bill we've identified so first off
um regarding section three of the bill
that establishes the setback from um and
I use the term portable water aquafer um
what line is that and what page um well
it's the whole section but I can let's
see uh page page one um L okay gotcha
thank you yeah so that that whole
section three it makes reference in the
I think in the first paragraph to
um the location of the facility relative
to a portable water aquifer and this is
really just a technical issue everybody
has a different idea what an aquafer is
for some people an aquafer is the ugala
aquafer out in the midwest that provides
you know covers several States and
provides water to thousands of people um
but the hydrogeologist definition of an
aquafer is is very Broad and it
basically means any formation water
bearing formation that can provide water
um to a user and that user could be an
individual home well um and potable just
means it's basically safe to drink so um
almost any landfill site that a new site
a greenfields landfill sighting is
likely to overly something you could def
with that definition you could Define as
an aquafer so just as you in order for
that section to be implementable I think
there would need to be a little bit of
more um exposition to explain or
definition a clearer definition of what
it means um and to talk about the
location of that site relative to a
pable water aquifer so again that's
um also um that same section makes
existing facilities
exempt um from the requirements and this
is just this is a general observation
that the department has raised in the
context of a number of bills and we've
made generally we there are times when I
think it's appropriate to exempt an
existing facility from a particular
requirement particularly when it's just
impracticable to implement it but where
we're talking about potentially
expanding existing facilities it's not
clear to the department why the members
of a community where a facility exists
deserve less less protective condition
conditions than the members of community
where a new facility is being proposed
so I'm not even sure where we would be
on that but I I just want to raise it I
think it's a question that that is
worthy of of consideration when you when
you look at a bill like this um also on
uh page two lines 1 through five it uses
the term maximum seepage velocity and um
in the context where it's used there
it's unclear whether that's a macroscale
evaluation of the
or a single location measurement and if
it's the ladder um it seems that it
could exclude virtually any site due to
a relative the presence of a relatively
small area or volume of a particular
soil type so um and that may not be
either could be neither contiguous nor
representative of the site and its
ability to move water so I just raised
that I think that's again a technical
issue where I think perhaps that Max
that term the use of the term maximum
cage velocity probably needs to be
looked at in terms of a clearer
definition um and another technical
issue on page uh um I think it's the
page
um would be page
two lines uh 16 through
18 um it uses the term fully permitted
and this is a again a technical issue
because it's basically saying that
expansions are or landfills are fully
permitted or exempt and the way that we
as I've said to this committee many
times we administer the solid waste
program and particular our landfill
regulatory program through a system of
permits and we're all you know virtually
any change you make or any new
advancement at a landfill there's a new
permit modification that needs to happen
so it could be read that if if the
desire of the bill is to expand those
facilities a an expansion that's been
approved at a landfill is not really
fully permitted until it's approved for
construction and it's given operational
approval and that happens very late in
the game so I think it's just again a
language thing that maybe should be
should be looked
at um also on page two line
19 um uses the term the phrase perennial
water bodies traversing a footprint and
it's not clear to me under what
circumstances that would occur this
suggests that there's a perennial water
body within the footprint of the
landfill uh and then talks about
monitoring that would be required for
that and um not clear that any that
circumstance would ever get a permit so
I'm not really sure it make it just
makes me think maybe I don't understand
what it's trying to accomplish so I
wanted to raise it um and then uh on uh
page two line 24 and going on it
oh again it describes the conduct of
subsurface
investigations um that that look at
surficial stratigraphy in Bedrock and
then it makes the uses the phrase at
least to a depth of nearby aquafers used
and that goes back to my comment before
about really defining aquafer I think
the meaning here is that there's an
offside aquifer that is nearby that is
used for drinking water but it isn't
really clear for that it isn't that that
isn't clear in the language so I think
that's maybe a technical issue that
should be should be should be looked at
um and then on and the sponsor has
acknowledged this but I just do want to
raise page two line
35 um to page three of line three uh it
excludes from consideration any sites
that are located within 10 miles of a
Superfund Site or 10 miles of another
landfill and I'm not really sure why
that is relevant um but even if it is it
be important to consider what that might
mean we have 22 super fund sites in New
Hampshire and and a number of landfills
including if you talking about online
landfills or 300 of those if you drew a
10 mile radius around every one of those
facilities I'm not sure any of the state
would be left so I want to just raise
that as a
um I guess two other issues that I think
the sponsor has acknowledged but I just
want to reiterate on page uh page three
15 lines 15 to 17 regarding the Ford act
um we' this has been vetted thoroughly
through the rulemaking process we're
confident that our rules invoke that and
that it's already it's a federal law it
applies anyways and our rules were were
amended to make it clear that the
applicant of a for a landfill needs to
notify the FAA of their application and
get a determination from them whether
there are any Ford Act applicable land
airports within a certain radius so
we're confident that that is
appropriately addressed and I don't
think it's necessary in this bill and
then lastly um again the sponsor
acknowledged um the page three lines 18
to 30 which has a lot of language that
would exclude um anybody who who's
committed any kind of violation of a
state law federal law local law permit
regulation um from getting a permit and
you know we we administer a compliance
Assurance program we're never out there
as much as we'd like to be but we're
always trying to do more and so we try
to get to our facilities and do a
thorough inspection and there are a lot
of requirements and there's always going
to be violations and so if as this is
written I don't think anybody that's
ever operated a landfill in New
Hampshire even if they're doing a really
good job could get a permit the way
that's written so I know that the
sponsors acknowledge a need to look at
that and and I would uh I would Echo
that and I'll uh I'll leave it at that
and um answer any questions you might
have representative ger thank you madam
chair thank you director for taking my
question uh and this is a question about
aquafers uh which I don't pretend to
understand in any great depth pun
intended um last year no laugh for that
at all okay thank you thank you U last
year uh we passed a bill that went on to
get signed by the governor it had to do
with classifying landfills as projects
of regional impact and part of that bill
in my recollection had to do with it
referred specifically to a table of
identified aquafers because that was
part of that legislation so my question
is uh do we not have a uh a kind of a
mapped out system because I'm trying to
remember what we referred to in that
bill it was watersheds watersheds I'm
sorry thank you very much Madam chair
that's what I was trying desperately to
remember thank
you representative B
so um it sounds like uh and and I the
prime sponsored acknowledged this there
is a certain amount of work to be done
on the bill uh and I don't think that I
think you've done a good job of Iden
identifying um uh items of concern uh I
don't think that we could get very far
by trying to like figure out the answers
to all of those right here and now but
would you be available to work with the
subcommittee to uh to put together an
amendment for this or advise on an
amendment we certainly uh assist the
committee and whatever you think would
be helpful thank you thank you any other
questions from the
committee seeing
none thank you very much for your coming
and um pointing out some of the uh
perhaps deficiencies or points where we
need refinement in this uh in this
important
bill I would invite representative
Scully to please sit down but if on your
hb77 and I would just like to say that
um the online portal reports 215 people
in support of this bill four in
opposition
and I have um
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 people in support of this
legislation on the blue sheet and one
person
opposed and if what I'm going to do is
close out the hearing for
hb77 I want to thank everybody who's
come today to speak on this
bill and I know we are running late uh
but we still have one before us which is
house resolution 10 uh we're running a
half hour late I hope that we can get
through this fairly quickly at the
hr10 um but this is a house resolution
recognizing the fundamental right to
have clean air clean water and a healthy
environment
so I believe the sponsor of that bill is
representative
gerana
and
um we all settle down
here please proceed thank you so much
thank you madam chair and I promise this
will be quick uh for the record my name
is Nick Jana I am I represent chesher 15
Hinsdale Chesterfield Kean Wards 1 and 3
through five Siri Walpole and
westerland uh unlike you know we had a
discussion earlier this morning
regarding uh house resolutions and and
how meaningful they are also some
discussion of the length of resolution
so I I hope my committee colleagues uh
will recognize the fact that this is an
extraordinarily short uh resolution
there are three very brief whereases so
hopefully that will be a selling point
for for some of my friends on the
committee uh very quickly in terms of
the reason why the motivation behind the
bill I am also not generally a big fan
of of house resolutions uh but as uh
some will recall last year there was a
proposed constitutional amendment to
this effect that was brought to this
committee and we had some good
discussion uh and some of my colleagues
on this committee and then on the house
uh said that they were entirely in
support of the spirit of the bill uh of
the Constitutional Amendment they were
just concerned about what were its
implications what are its ramifications
will there be lawsuits what does this
mean in terms of practical uh
application uh and so what I have
brought you today in the form of a house
resolution is a statement about
regarding the fundamental right to a
clean and healthy environment that has
no practical application whatsoever
right so I hope that my my colleagues
who last year said they supported the
spirit of the bill but were concerned
because of possible implications will
not now argue that they can't support it
when it has no practical
implications the logic of the bill is
that the right to a clean and healthy
environment is a fundamental right and I
would argue the most fundamental right
we articulate in our our United States
Constitution and in our state
constitution a series of fundamental
rights freedom of speech freedom of
religion the right to bear arms uh Etc
uh but my argument is that the right to
a clean and healthy environment is
actually the fundamental right uh our
ability to enjoy our other rights our
ability to exercise our other rights uh
is really grounded in the notion that we
have a clean and healthy and safe place
to do those things um so in that sense
as you can see in the short whereas
section of the bill
uh this bill contends that uh our
ability to enjoy our other already
recognized fundamental rights is
contingent upon our ability to enjoy
this one uh and I just want to
close uh by saying that fundamental
rights have to be declared even if it's
in a document like this that doesn't
necessarily not necessarily doesn't have
any uh legal impact and they have to be
declared uh this one has to be declared
because we decided we're not going in
the direction of Constitutional
Amendment but we should at least be able
to do this in the form of a resolution
we should at least be able to say
officially that we recognize this as a
fundamental right it is literally the
least we can do uh and
that is all I have in terms of my
introduction I'm happy to answer any
questions representa
wheeler thank you madam chair and thank
you representative gerana for bringing
this forward and apologies if I've
grimaced at anyone I have contacts that
are getting real dry I shouldn't have
warned them when reading today if I
Grimace at you it's not cuz I it's just
cuz I'm trying to see you um I really
appreciate you bringing forward this
resolution and I'm wondering do you view
this as comparable to uh in the New
Hampshire Constitution how we outline
that a right to a good education is is a
part to uh the fundamental nature of
society such as you know do you view it
as comparable meeting this is a clean
healthy environment fundamental to our
society and New Hampshire's already
recognized some of those fundamental
rights within its Constitution and I
would you believe that this is a a good
jump off of where the Constitution is
currently thank you representative uh I
certainly would believe that right the
Constitution says that in order to
exercise our rights as Citizens and to
perform our duty as Citizens the state
has a requirement to support education
in this state and I see this as being a
foundational right in that same sense so
thank
committee
[Music]
um no no questions no told you it' be
quick well I mean I I I guess I do have
a question as in so far as the
definition of a
right
um I mean you know we we we kind of
throw that around that you know I have a
right to housing I have a right to food
you know I have a right to
whatever um and and I and I get
that I
think um my question to you
is how do you view this as a
right thank you very much uh Madam
chairman that's a great question I'm
going to trying to think about how to
make this decision because as a
historian of ideas I would be happy to
talk at length about the history of the
debate about what right is but I will
you know we but but we do take this
seriously in so far as you know we talk
about constitutional rights the right to
life liberty The Pursuit of Happiness
yes um and natural rights but um there
are certain things I believe that you
can guarantee in life and some things
that you cannot guarantee in life um so
I just want to know where where you are
what your um what your definition or
perception is of a right thank you
though I think that's a fabulous
question and I would say it's something
which is essential to the Dignity of
personhood right that when we Define our
rights in terms of the right to speech
and the right to practice our religion
and the right to defend ourselves and
and our property and our family these
are rights which are and that's why I
mean of course the phrase we all know is
in inali inalienable or unalienable
right and and by that Jefferson meant a
right which Belongs To You by The Very
essential nature of the dignity that you
hold as a human being um and and I see
this as a right in that respect your
ability to as I said live to pursue
happiness to take care of your family
etc etc depends on your ability to live
in an environment which is guaranteed at
least some measure of safety we we have
all kinds of laws to guarantee our
personal safety in terms of uh being uh
impacted by other people but safety is
also about our ability to live in an
environment that is also not posing a
danger to our essential dignity as a
human being so uh I don't know if that
helps but uh to me uh the question
ultimately is to what are we entitled by
the very nature of our personhood and if
these other rights that we speak of
religion and the right to bear arms and
and the freedom of speech are essential
which I believe they are I believe this
is just as essential to our ability to
uh you to recognize the fundamental
Dignity of each of our
personhoods okay representative King
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking questions are you familiar with
the differences in definitions of
positive and negative rights and the
differences between the two and if so do
you view the rights delineated in this
house resolution as positive or negative
rights thank you that's a great question
so it's like do you have the freedom to
or do you have the freedom from right is
the essence of a a positive right is the
right to do something a negative right
is the right not to be infringed by
something right um and the right has to
actually when we think about the freedom
of religion it contains both right you
have the right to practice your religion
but you also have the freedom from
infringement upon that right right so it
is in a sense both a positive and a
negative right and the essence of a
right in our system in our system of
liberal Western democracy is that my
rights end at the bridge of your nose
right so my positive right goes to the
point where it infringes upon the right
of another individual right so in this
case I think that it is both uh it is
fundamentally a negative right in the
sense that it is a sense of safety in
the same way that your right to defend
yourself is a sense of safety um the
question I think where we got into the
Constitutional Amendment this is all
getting into the weeds but when we were
talking about the Constitutional
amendment I think the question was well
what would it mean if you asserted this
as a positive right right what are you
entitled to what legal actions are you
entitled to pursue that would be the
question of if this were applied as a
positive right but the negative right I
think here that is a defense from
infringement of your personal freedoms I
would compare here to our freedom to
defend
ourselves thank you very much I
appreciate that answer representative
coma thank you madam chair and thank you
representative so my question is is what
does clean and healthy mean who defines
that and who
determines
that I think that's an excellent
question and that is a reason why people
voted against uh this is a
constitutional amendment I'm not sure
that we need to split those hairs when
we're talking about a house resolution
and I don't mean to be flipping I
literally just mean offering it as a
house resolution as opposed to say a
bill or a constitutional amendment I
don't think requires us to get into that
granular level of detail to Define what
applied representative
Howard couldn't we just um let everybody
sort of run with their own idea of clean
and and pure and you know healthy
environment right we might all have a
different idea but we can all believe in
that yes and I would say we've been
arguing for almost 250 years about what
the right to bear arms is right so there
isn't one answer to that question the
freedom of speech we have all kinds of
limitations on the freedom of speech
freedom of religion is Up For Debate in
terms of positive and negative rights
right so I would say any of our
fundamental rights uh and and
representative comp was I don't
literally didn't mean to be dismissive
of your question it's a question that is
true of all of our fundamental rights
how do you define them where do you draw
the lines absolutely so I think that
there is enough common agreement on what
this means that for a house resolution a
statement by the house if we were
looking at a bill or Constitutional
Amendment right then we would be asking
a separate set of questions I
think representative gr guber thank you
madam chair um uh thank you for drafting
this too um it seems to me that these
words can ever be fully defined
particularly in this case it doesn't
matter you know to that degree but it
does recognize our social values that we
actually value clean air clean you know
water healthy environment and that we're
making a statement that we value this
and that it's valuable for everybody so
and since it doesn't have the force of
law at least we're making a value
judgment which is I think important
thank you yes thank you I'm glad you did
a very nice job of getting right to the
point is a value statement uh in the end
and I'd also say in terms of this
question of how do we Define it uh I
have a granddaughter who's now about
five months old the newest member of our
family uh and if you think about your
loved ones your children your
grandchildren you
know what it means to want a clean and
healthy environment for them right and
again are do we need to Define that no
because of the nature of a resolution
it's a value statement and I think in
the end we have a lot more consensus
about what it means me then we would
disagreement any other questions from
the committee seeing none I'd like the
blue sheet please from the um from the
table and um I would yeah and I also
need a pink slip from you thank you very
much um online in the online portal we
have 189 people supporting
hr10 three in
sheet we
have three six seven people who signed
in in support of
hr10 and with that I'm going to end the
hr10
and um that ends our public hearings and
our work for today
um I am going to
be probably sitting down for a few
minutes with uh representative Bixby to
and representative ktoa going over uh
the plan for next Tuesday when we will
rejourn and uh talk about more bills and
have more hearings and do more work so I
want to thank you all for being here
today and um your very good questions to
uh the folks who testified and uh your
your working attention uh all day long
so thank you and U we'll see you next
week we are do I hear a motion to